what is up people of the world it is
July 22.
the dark baby
[Music]
you know what it is
happy Friday everybody
on Friday yo show off your um leggings
those are pretty fly they keep falling
off oh really are those are those aren't
Teddy fresh are they
spot that
slap that foot on the desk
slap it up there that's it oh
oh [ __ ] damn dominate me Mommy I want to
smell feet stomp on me
anyway welcome how you doing Eula good
thank you how are you I'm good thank you
nice how was your week
it's been good I think I don't know
what about you you don't know no idea
um
regular regular regular it's been nice
that we've been able to swim with the
nice summer weather we've been swimming
with Theodore a lot it's all he wants to
do now is swim yeah
he'll be like 10 minutes before bedtime
I wanna swim
anyway
um also you guys should be happy to know
that I'm all [ __ ] up once again on
benadryls can anybody guess why
I'm taking guesses why am I [ __ ] up on
Benadryl and my face and eyelid
specifically are superior itchy and
puffy
that's right it's the fika fish I think
it's got I mean I don't understand what
else it could be at this point
um
but um
what's up with the audio are they
pranking or is there something wrong no
wait there's audio
they hear me though yeah it's just we've
we Dan fixed it okay audio audio
it's like saying Beetlejuice three times
you know audio audio Yeah
is it fixed guys yeah okay yeah I think
so
how bad is it everyone's just spamming
it just sounded super eq'd it's all good
now we're good okay
audio is fixed my friends
um
what was I saying yes why am I on
Benadryl
I'm pretty sure that it's got to be the
fika fish because the last time I had
this crazy rash all over my face yep and
it's when I licked the fika fish this
time I only dump I dumped my fingers in
it and smelled it just touching it and I
washed my fingers really good
still did it I still touched myself
pretty good for life I just I don't know
I'm not I don't have any allergies but
there's something in that feak of fish
that ain't right
cerebral palsy maybe it's the
um poison
in there do you expect it's literally uh
Rotting Flesh yeah it turns out I'm
allergic to Rotting Flesh ladies and
gentlemen not such a bad thing to be uh
allergic to yeah I'll never be
accountable guys uh just just not made
for that kind of stuff never ever do it
it is dead it is
so
um anyway yes yes here we are I am half
asleep because I've been all fricked up
on Benadryl
you know I got to tell you guys the
weekend's coming up oh big announcement
tomorrow right at what did we say too
you were saying two yeah
we're all good with that like with
babysitters and stuff yeah we could do
one
yeah one's better you guys good with one
yeah good one ever okay I got nothing
going on
is that okay for you I don't know if
you're being sarcastic no no I'm I'm
being serious
tomorrow at one we are having a members
only live stream where we will be
watching the infamous and long-awaited
potatoes uh the role of a lifetime Gary
Oldman
and can only what be it could only be
described as one of the worst most
offensive movies ever and they were so
full of themselves when they made it
they really thought they were doing
Oscar bait with that Gary Oldman walking
around on his knees so so I invite all
of you guys
All You Beautiful members to join us
tomorrow we're gonna watch the whole
goddamn movie you know what's funny
about tiptoes that [ __ ] is two and a
half hours yeah you know with those
kinds of shitty rom-coms you're like 90
minutes I was like how how the [ __ ]
much store how much do you have to say
are we gonna allow A10 to pause it
because we'll be here 10 hours I know I
thought about that I don't think so I
think no pausing out loud people won't
be able to sync it up if you pause it
okay well I don't think they're gonna
have to we figured out a way I don't
think you're gonna have to buy the movie
or
um sync it you can watch along with us
right then that's that's the plan
yeah we figured out a way
yeah we're gonna play the movie and just
go for the best no but stand before you
because it's not a joke it's commentary
yeah yeah also like Mystery Theater of
10 billion where they just sit in front
of the screen so we're going to set up a
green screen right yeah so we'll be on
the bottom of it and then we'll screen
the movie and
um and I guess let's see how that goes
yeah we'll see how it goes uh I I think
it'll be fine for the stream I guess we
should say because we're just going to
play the movie
pretty decent chance it gets blocked
after the fact so be there alive go
claim it I don't think they'll block it
even if it's like the whole thing even
if it's just for members they it still
applies like I think it'll be fine for
the stream I just wonder if after the
fact it'll uh get taken down I don't
think they really look at like um
how much you watch right whether it
detects it or not right we'll do it live
but as far as I know they don't want to
claim this movie they want to pretend
this movie doesn't it
maybe maybe nothing will happen but yeah
it's going to be a lot of fun it's Dan's
birthday too so it's gonna be a whole
birthday
we're celebrating your birthday which is
today was yesterday yes wait wait what
my birthday was yesterday your birthday
was yesterday happy birthday thank you
how did it go oh I was confused about
that yeah I don't know how was your
birthday yeah it was good I was here uh
working for the majority of God I forgot
to wish you happy birthday God I thought
it was tomorrow well we're celebrating
it tomorrow you did you did oh I did
yeah you don't have to apologize you you
wish me happy birthday thank you he
meant to say I mean it though yeah
I say it every day today I just in case
just in case right because I'm so I
don't want to miss it
well happy birthday then thank you thank
you happy birthday but anyway I'm super
excited it's gonna be a lot of fun
tomorrow it's gonna be drinks Pizza uh
Thrills and you can actually join us
this time maybe because the last one we
did it was for your fight you're right
I'm excited it looked fun last time yeah
it was really fun
um I wonder what kind of food should we
be getting since it's Dan's birthday uh
party where's Dan uh I don't know but
it's also sort of Cam's birthday too oh
yeah Kim what did you want to eat
tomorrow you requested Fried Chicken
Fried Chicken baby [ __ ] oh yeah baby
okay and do you have any specific place
that you like or you just want generally
Fried Chicken anywhere is good I'm down
for whatever
interesting are you over the Buffalo
calzone because I was thinking to get
some of those for you oh I'm down for
that too yeah that works instead of
fried chicken I'm down for whatever man
um are you guys ready for the other
thing Sam
okay yeah also it's Cam's birthday we
have a surprise a big surprise for you
Kim did you know that no I not really no
I did not not really things up not look
back there or something here
no what what
we'll take care of it it's okay we're
we're working on bringing it out it's a
pretty big deal though
really do you have any idea what it is
no clue is it a buffalo chicken calzone
it's the biggest buffalo cheese calzone
ever is it really I had no idea this was
going to happen that was better it's
better than a buffalo we have a
blindfold by your desk uh okay put it on
in a little bit okay oh you guys aren't
ready yet Ian they're grabbing it now
can we get a drum rolls out or well
drum rolls I'll let you know when when I
see it all right
so it's not a buffalo cheese calzone you
want what you want to guess what else it
is
um
a lemur
a what down a lemur lemur oh a lemur no
lemur and it's not I don't deal in
exotic animals
but I'll tell you what there's something
I want to tell you guys about while we
wait for Cam's present to be ready I am
a junkie for reality television show as
you guys probably know by now and F boy
Island season two is yeah it's really
good super legit I like it
the first season I didn't love I'll be
honest really well it ended the ending
yeah the ending was really good
but the second season is very
entertaining I stopped watching halfway
through the first season yeah oh it's
worth finishing maybe I do this season
yeah the ending of the first season was
epic yeah really just the last episode
basically is it because like two no
spoilers I think I can spoil them first
so is it like they fell in love and it
turned out he was a [ __ ] boy yeah well
not only that he was a [ __ ] boy and then
at the end they have the option to take
a hundred thousand or share it did he
take it and he took it all for himself
okay I have to watch that is awesome and
then the ultimate twist was that uh
she's like okay [ __ ] boy well here's
another twist we're donating your all
the money to charity
so he is it's really cool the second
season's back it's good
we're ready for uh Pam all right Cameron
put on your blindfold please
it's time to bring out Cameron's
epic birthday present
in honor of the cameli
the great family how old are you Kim
97 97 years old oh oh you lost one
yeah wow yep a little bit more there you
go oh my God
all right Cam hold on there
[Music]
it's something you've been wanting
something you've been asking for can I
take off my Michael go ahead go ahead
you can take it off now
oh hey it is a backdraw
let's go
I love this so much
happy birthday Cameron happy birthday
[Music]
it's a backdrop this completes the vibe
man before it was just all the like 10
million office chairs behind there and
this is awesome thank you so much so did
Sam make this and yeah or sure did thank
you very much Sam you're welcome
hey but I paid for the supplies Cameron
I'm sorry I paid for the supplies oh and
thank you very much
don't forget about me
I have to pay Sam okay so you know thank
you very much
uh there's actually somebody else we
shouldn't forget about
[Music]
[ __ ] baby
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
I did hate them
oh wow what do you have Baskin Robbins
get around this baby what flavor you got
in there
Mitten chip Rocky Road oh [ __ ] [ __ ] baby
it's Friday not really not like
disturbing to people listening to the
show but how loud yeah
this is a general
um setting so I can't really see these
[Music]
suck on my tits [ __ ]
[Laughter]
in my woo man
[Applause]
how about this one
suck my horse whoo [ __ ] my horse there
you go that's what that would work who
in my butt
let's get it
in my butt whoop in my butt nice nice
they're gonna think there's an owl in
there oh
[ __ ] baby [ __ ]
oh it's pretty empty there you you're
okay um
Family yeah
so how often do you get ice cream Gabe
that's kind of sweet that you do that
for yourself every week or after lunch
you know kind of thing that's nice when
I want to have a Yin for ice cream I'll
get some right now right now back to
Robin yeah I used to work I used to work
at Baskin-Robbins like 10 11 years ago
oh
it's kind of like my old job is that the
place you used to work
it's a different one but it's it's good
it's good ice cream yeah and um why did
you leave your your last job
uh opportunities and then one I got a
job closer to my house oh okay okay okay
that makes sense and when when you used
to scoop ice cream would you make like a
super big scoop for the people or would
were you kind of just buy the books
I have to go buy the book you know if
you go buy a super big scoop it's kind
of like you're eating up the process and
stuff you're a good employees Gabe
you're a good man what's your favorite
flavor
thank you
oh
I'll pee in my bed what what chip and um
pralines and cream that's like one of my
favorites yeah I love mint and chips oh
[ __ ] baby [ __ ]
oh
oh
they're like what is this guy doing are
they listening
they're definitely wondering what's
going on over there
yeah well that's what it is you know it
is what it is right I mean you're just
being yourself if they have a problem
with that [ __ ] baby [ __ ] them right I
don't want to get a complaint and then I
don't want to get kicked out of here
yeah
okay fair enough I gotta be I mean I
know it's customer service you want to
be respectful to customers but yeah they
don't want to disrupt their business
either so I gotta respect that okay yeah
[Applause]
this is Jimmy Lee yeah
all right Gabe well you're a good man I
like that you're out there treating
yourself to ice cream I think we should
we could all take a note you know we
should all be treating ourselves to ice
cream more often it's called self-care
right gab right self-care oh yeah 31
Flavors baby 31 flavor flavors of this
dish
[ __ ] put that ice cream up my ass [ __ ]
time that was worth it yeah that's good
that's good
all right hey you take care you have a
good weekend okay bud love you have a
good weekend and
happy weekend baby
has risen
[Laughter]
[Music]
harmonize with me ready
oh
no not that the sound I'm just wetting
my lips
yeah
all right thanks babe
love you so much all right have a good
weekend buddy we love you okay take care
I thought it was done
it is Friday baby you know during the
Olympics someone goes and likes the
torch
that's Gabe for the weekend oh it ain't
Friday till you hear that
you know what it is
good man actually really really
conscientious and thoughtful of of uh
the people around him and also what a
great employee we learned no big Scoops
profit he prioritized the prophet of uh
Baskin Robbins which is really good
sounds like a good guy it's no sponsors
today thank you I'll sponsor yeah you
will
Teddy fresh next release is coming out
next week by the way look at this
Winnie the Pooh sir
[Music]
swag swag swag
swag
I love that very nice swag is that
because uh is Winnie the Pooh yes sir
the main now yes yes
we heard that Winnie the Pooh was
um public domain so we said
swag swag swag swag swag
being public domain is some people are
going absolutely crazy for it like
someone's making up some horror movie
about Winnie the Pooh really that he
like eats people
it's pretty crazy we just wanted to make
a nice shirt about it
swag
I also wanted to say that the sale was
awesome and thank you to everyone that
um bought stuff I saw a lot of people
say it's their first order yeah that's
awesome so I'm really excited for all
these people
um
I think you know I think the product is
good so anybody that if their first
order is going to be happy yeah you guys
are gonna love it if you don't let us
know
um you know and our employees we keep
them sedated and chained up so they'll
be they'll be available to answer your
emails 24 7.
no I was I kind of was thinking about
putting it behind the scenes as a joke
like the whole portrait downstairs then
we went downstairs and there's this
crazy party we could we probably just
have pizza there like all the time I go
in there and I'm just like [ __ ]
because they're eating pizza it reminds
me of the office they seem to have a
party like every week yeah
somebody was leaving and someone's it
was the birthday of someone's daughter
who happened to be there and I brought
Theodore with me yesterday so all of a
sudden it became a sport spontaneous
party with karaoke machine Theodore was
having fun he stole the show yeah and
everybody stood in a circle and Theodore
was like dancing in the middle he's
Hamming it up did I tell you guys that
video
there was like a whole circle everybody
was in there I recorded that and then
Theodore loves this song from Madagascar
the cartoon where it goes I like to move
it move it it's his favorite song and
they were doing karaoke
so there was like 20 people around
Theodore and he was chomping it up dude
he had great he was just loving it man
he was dancing like a man no stage fear
whatsoever yeah like this kid is so
brave we had him on that mic yesterday
yeah he was hanging out with us oh yeah
he wants to be on the podcast and to he
loves making his favorite thing is
before bed now we get out our phone and
we make videos together it's so crazy
like that came from him I don't even
know how it started he just told me like
he wanted me to open the phone and I
thought he'd mean like take a picture
and then it was like no like record oh
interesting and then before bed we were
obviously reading like five books you
know always like another one another one
and now it's just he just wants to
record videos and then he records
himself and then he wants to watch it
right afterwards he cracks out like
he goes Theodore Klein here oh yeah
they were having a photo shoot
downstairs and he walked past and he
goes I want to do a photo shoot I was
like okay well that's Dan upstairs and
we came upstairs I was like pretending I
was like he goes why are you pretending
yeah
that's crazy yeah you know got the bug I
don't know where he got it from but God
help him like I really make sure not to
push him in into any direction because I
don't want that to be the vibe I've
never liked seeing it
um when other people do it like you know
I don't know family channels on YouTube
or just like kid dancers you know when
the parents push them so hard
um so I never want to like influence him
too much because like obviously we have
so many like Direction he could go like
with fashion or with the videos but this
is all coming from him I don't
necessarily want him to do like videos
or no or anything kind of scary I have
no desire or preconceives a desire for
him to do that I mean it's it's a good
job but it's like um it's always the
best job and it's pretty [ __ ] up to
have your whole life be public yeah so I
don't I'm not asking I'm not you know
what I mean I'm worried about it man and
he's already out there [ __ ]
looking for the Limelight yeah from what
I've seen he's very much like you Ethan
yeah very much very much well we asked
him when he was up here yeah we were
like what do you want to be when you
grow up and he's like a clown
say that that's a little bit of a clown
he has never said clown he said clown
usually says trash truck driver or
and when he was making a bracelet Lino's
saying we're gonna put your name on it
he said Put uh Lena what what did he say
silly so yeah
yeah I we did bracelets and like because
I I personally I enjoy it so I try to
get him to do stuff that I like too it
doesn't go that well oh you know what
else happened yesterday was uh I was I
said hi to him and you guys remember so
like during the lockdown days we were
doing the show at the house so I was
going over to Ethan and Ila's house all
the time and Theodore really took a
liking to me we get like so excited
whenever I showed up and I was like hey
hey Theodore you remember me and he was
like
I don't know and then like later I was
like don't you remember I used to come
to the basement all the time and he was
like thought for a second he's like oh
that was when I was a baby yeah
like nine months ago
oh that is like a third of his life
right yeah yeah it was true if I if I'm
asking about something that happened
like a day or two ago he goes oh that
was a long time ago
[Laughter]
but um yeah we're making bracelets and
as I try to write like cute things and
then he's like let's write silly fart
and um yeah and then Shredder puked
because sometimes he does that and then
he wanted he made a bracelet with me
saying silly puke
yeah it's pretty crazy man what's going
on at home there
but that's what it is y'all
Zach how's your toe now man Zach we
talked about his ingrown toenail and I
have pictures of it should I should be
let me I oh I didn't want to say that it
doesn't look that bad to me Zach
um like I know how painful it is it
happens to me too yeah uh there's
another picture I took before I went in
the procedure and it was just oozing pus
which I will I will save you from from
viewing that so this photo you did a
procedure well I'm in more pain now
yeah because I went to a podiatrist that
isn't my main dude and uh I was
screaming bloody murder yes no it was
the worst experience of my life what
happened and the last time it was like
pain relief and now this time it's like
increased pain so when I normally go to
my main podiatrist who's out of town
this week he just you know goes in and
doesn't numb me or anything like that
and just gets the nail out it's like
five seconds of discomfort and that's it
yeah you're good to go yeah this
[ __ ] dude like
he's like he's like all right well I'm
gonna have to numb your first off he was
he was old as [ __ ] this guy oh I hate
super old dogs he looked like just like
becoming an ages I don't care he looked
just like doctor now from my 600 pound
life okay like just like him yeah you're
fat
um
so he's like all right well I'm gonna
have to numb your toe and I'm like well
can't you just go in and you know just
snip it out a little bit and he's like
well that sounds kind of barbaric and
I'm like why what so then he he covers
the area of me looking at my toe oh I
can't see it he puts like a tarp over
and I've never had that before and this
[ __ ] takes the Clippers and goes
so [ __ ] far down
gushing blood everywhere I'm screaming
bloody murder like [ __ ] stop [ __ ]
stop [ __ ] stop and he wouldn't stop
he won't stop he won't stop no I can't
with doctors like that he he taught you
a lesson he said you better take the
[ __ ] in yeah
next time but like I when I normally go
I don't I don't get that
so is it possible to that that this was
a worse infection
our worst uh worse and grown toenail
yeah probably just progressed since last
time could it have just been a worse
situation
well possibly yeah it it hurt I wouldn't
say it's my worst but it was definitely
up there
can I so this photos you put are after
the procedure this is after the warning
if you don't like seeing toes but it's
not gory it's actually not that bad it's
really not but here it goes
yeah so yeah dude you can see so he
removed this whole part of the nail it
[ __ ] hurt like a mother fam dude I
was screaming where's cement at yeah I
know so when you guys showed Zach on the
show when you showed it that was before
the procedure yes that was on Wednesday
when he was gonna go there afterwards so
at that point
um I was wondering I was gonna ask you
about it I didn't know you were gonna
have a procedure already but you can't
you can't clip it yourself Zack I've
tried yeah
um I just find I ended up I end up
[ __ ] it up more
when I do it myself and I'd rather just
go and just because I trust my the main
Podiatry should I go to with my life
like the guy knows how to get it real
well but
um yeah but I just listen
I'm getting a little bit bitter with
like really old people that don't quit
their job when they need when they need
to retire
like like if you're a doctor and you're
like 80 years old no I'm sorry this we
need to talk about this why it's
happening and mostly tapping in politics
it's happening as Senators
Representatives the [ __ ] presidency
I'm tired of old people running the
[ __ ] country and by the way uh well
you don't have to go to them okay so
it's different in that case but
if you're 80 years old you're just
probably not up to date with [ __ ] no
he's not and he probably got shaky ass
hands too
thinking a little bit I was debating bro
I was debating like should I just get
the no but what about you know that some
culture is like you're supposed to
respect the elderly like their wisdom
yeah well if they were it's like not a
thing anymore let's listen
no it is still a thing but the thing is
like
you know do you want a [ __ ]
eight-year-old person driving a kid's
bus or some [ __ ] you know the Bus full
of kids I mean you can respect but the
old people in your life but also be like
I don't think a 80 year old should be
president
sorry dude
just got to be real about it
um
I say we [ __ ] euthanize people at 80
straight up oh God are you trying to
we're not I'm kidding I'm kidding stop
I'm kidding
I don't like this whole thing right now
about ageism I would rather just talk
about the toenail listen sometimes you
just make a stand okay I agree with you
I'm tired of the world
there's not enough opportunities for
young people in the world already as it
is and these people never want to pass
the [ __ ] Reigns
Salt Lake City
gracefully pass the range to the younger
generation you can't you've got to
[ __ ] go you've got to go retire
sometimes people are old and it's Gotta
stop well I just want to say by the time
they graduate they're like 35 if you're
gonna specialize in okay so I just
wanted for you 35 year run yeah so it
goes one of two ways either they're a
master of their craft or they're too old
for it look whatever reason I'm saying
does not represent me or how I run my
business thank you
either just to be clear just because
they haven't applied right back in the
days in Scandinavia they used to kill
old people they threw them off like or
they they made them jump off uh big
mountains that's what the [ __ ]
talking about [ __ ] mid-summer right
love
the show cause if this is how we're
starting today
I love giving up our background is that
like a viking thing
uh well they did it in Viking culture
and I think I don't know how real it is
but it's definitely like a story that uh
you get told every now and then it's
called and that's respect yeah and it's
like suicide because they do it they
think it's a respectful thing to do so
it's not forced usually I think exactly
wisdom means jumping off a bridge when
you're 80. yeah death to all of them am
I right well listen my uncle was 79 when
my cousin Tim was born and what he's
brought so much to my life your cousin
or your my uncle I'm sorry my my uncle
Tim's dad was 79 when Tim was born how
much did he bring to Tim's life
I brought him a lot of money yeah he
inherited a lot but no he he okay
whatever I don't I don't I'm not making
a comment about having kids at 79. I'm
just saying okay people are saying why
is he less scared of being canceled
maybe because he got a banned already
and you had to not make a podcast for a
week fair to ELA yeah I I don't know are
you just trying to take a week off maybe
yeah no but actually if we get another
strike it'll be two weeks right
I'm not what am I getting for bruh I
can't we're saying all the people should
um I'm that's a joke come on
bro I don't think all people should kill
them so sons of [ __ ] but just [ __ ]
yeah but anyway I don't know I I'm just
gonna you know I used to be like oh
ageism [ __ ] you know give them a break I
just think personally it's getting out
of [ __ ] control there's not enough
opportunities for young people and old
people are not passing the range off
they're hanging on for too [ __ ] long
and it's like becoming a real problem
that's it you wanna do you want a real
Counterpoint to that sure
and at least in this country the ability
for a lot of people to retire has been
taken away over the last several decades
because of the social safety nets being
gutted over and over again Reagan
implementing income tax on social
security benefits all that kind of stuff
and people have to work longer and so
it's not always their fault like not
everybody can can retire not everybody
has that option I think the ones that
you are talking about that you have a
very fair point on are the politicians
the average age of Congress is like
[ __ ] what what was it we looked it up
on leftovers dude
that that's a problem but that's
different than than people who are
working yeah so obviously if you're like
assault of the earth worker thing I
agree there's not good opportunities out
there the fact that you have to work is
[ __ ] up and horrible right that's but
I'm talking about like the elite people
with desirable jobs I I don't disagree
with wanna [ __ ] relinquish the torch
I don't disagree either I just think the
word obviously if you can't retire then
then then obviously you know you've got
to work and God bless them for that and
damn this country also from forcing them
to work
there we go we got we landed at a good
compromise okay so you guys agree with
that okay good obviously I'm not talking
about like an eight-year-old who's been
working at [ __ ] Target his whole life
or what he's like yeah I mean that sucks
dude shout out to you bro follow the
Earth all right we're talking about this
one he's not stealing opportunities
being a [ __ ] Walmart cashier right
right fair enough
all right there you go thank you
everybody
it's just been eating me up
it's been eating me up I had to say it
um anyway can you cut the camera in real
fast Cameron I want to see the backdrop
nice he's so happy look at this man
um looks fantastic Cameron you look
right at home there
I feel right at home I love it so much
I'm super enthused right now you have no
idea Cameron is very nice Cameron is a
very nice guy
foreign
okay
um
what else we got here uh
I gotta say I hope you keep podcasting
until you're 82 so we have stable
employment right
that's a good question when should I
retire well am I saying am I stealing
opportunities by being a podcaster at 80
because it's like specifically my show
no probably not yeah so everyone but me
retired this does not apply to me no I
ain't doing this [ __ ] at 80 come on who
you kidding
watch this [ __ ] bro this Tech talk is
[ __ ] awesome it went Mega viral on
Tick Tock and it's got like Millions
tens of millions of views yo this [ __ ]
slaps you ready
[Applause]
old lady looking out the window
I thought it was like Gordon Ramsay for
a second okay
somebody pointed out on like the sub or
something that it kind of looks like
shoe nice let's take a second look
I don't see shoe nice oh wait is it a
woman or a man I can't tell oh man so
dude I think here we go at that moment
in time when that that's a morph that's
like that's another being that's on
another Island yeah so fine I don't see
the shoe nice to be uh I've been snoring
drain them all day
we almost did almost went overboard
oh that's so funny
a little cheer me up there you know what
I'm saying hey you guys are you guys in
the mood for some crazy chiropractors uh
Shenanigans okay
by the way this video is like two
minutes long I when I screened it I feel
like the first half of it is like pretty
innocuous so I don't know if you want to
skip a little bit further I'll skip it
got it gets wild though
yeah
Chiropractic is all pseudoscience sorry
to everyone who uses it looks painful by
the way there's like a whole um
there's a bunch of chiropractors I found
on Tick Tock now who are like just so
you know this is all [ __ ] like
realigning spine movement cracking and
all this [ __ ] just so you know it's all
pseudoscience he's like the only way to
make your back feel better as a
chiropractor is like stretching and
exercises he's like all these people are
reporting there's a couple of them no he
doesn't do that stuff he does like he
teaches the clients how to how to
stretch and what exercises they do so
are they a chiropractor are they just
like he's a chiropractor licensed
chiropractor oh yeah
he just says they're all there the whole
most of the interview she's just
scamming people with this bad advice
after I gave birth so many
I I think I got a massage and I also at
another place somebody like two
different people or three asked me if I
got it adjusted after giving birth and I
was like what are you a car I have no
idea what you're talking about
adjusted that's such a nice way of
saying it I'ma crack your [ __ ] bones
here we go nothing's adjusted nothing
moves like it's that's the whole thing
Lena you worked in a chiropractor office
yeah I did were the chiropractor they
weren't your family members were they
they were emotions
okay I could talk
well in my experience chiropractors are
like I you know I don't want to throw up
and leave his family into the bus that's
okay I mean in my experience
chiropractors are [ __ ] weirdos almost
exclusively I yeah and I would say in my
hometown at least a lot of chiropractors
become close friends with the lawyers
misconduct
[Music]
yeah I don't know
let me let me be clear let me be clear
not Lena's uncle but I'm just saying a
lot of the ones that are there's a lot
of people my age that want to go into
Chiropractic uh
yeah because they see the way they're
living really for personal injury claims
like if you have an attorney already and
you don't have a doctor then the
attorney will refer you to a certain
chiropractor and vice versa
a little and that's why they develop
like a close relationship
the great thing about being a
chiropractor too is that you don't
actually have to do anything you only
have to convince them
that some there's no like tangible
like oh it's fixed it's like you can
convince people through a
Placebo that is that it worked and that
can help but like you there's no metric
of like actually being a good
psychiatrist it's like totally doo-doo a
chiropractor let's just watch the
[ __ ] video
that's the kind of the way it is right
oh cool [ __ ] diseases bro just use your
brain guys it doesn't work it doesn't
make sense the shoulder blade is not
actually attached the body but other
than soft tissue okay
I know it gave me so we can actually yo
stop bro you're hurting him
this is not supposed to what are you
doing
it looks like a Mortal Kombat fatality
imagine
stop
s
he's gotta stop doing that
[Laughter]
Who's Laughing [ __ ] up
gnarly you feel great later yeah I mean
I think in theory people you know
they're in such chronic pain
unfortunately that they turn to every
solution people do uh chiropractor
people do uh the needle [ __ ] what's the
needle [ __ ]
people swear by this stuff too yeah and
because and I think Placebo it's
powerful because like for example you
read this book about how back pain is
caused by anxiety yes are you calling my
book Placebo no I was just no I'm saying
that the Mind pain connection Dr Sarno
yeah okay yeah I'm not saying it you're
the book was Placebo what I'm saying is
the Mind connection
is so powerful that your back pain went
away for a long time just by reading
this book my point is is that if people
believe it's working it can actually
alleviate the pain
yeah I swear by that book you read it
too yeah yeah
Howard's recommendation yes that's how
Ethan heard him talk about it and then
Ethan bought me the book yeah
it I mean like
I can't explain it it worked like magic
it's very weird yeah yeah the book
basically said what's the book called
because people are going to be curious
uh then ten ways to cure back pain
something like that no
anyway his theory is that like you carry
your anxiety and your back
it's not just a bag necessarily there's
like lower back or mine was like
specifically here
um but
it's it's about like how yeah how the
Stress and Anxiety
um and things like that can manifest
itself in like physical pain right it's
called Uh healing back pain the Mind
Body Connection yes yeah and you know if
you have chronic back pain
I would recommend reading it seems like
it's helped a lot of people I totally
would read it
um I had like this pain and it would
just come and go and and
every time that it came back it became
worse and worse and like it started like
30 minutes it would hurt and then it
would be like a whole day and then it
was like three days it won't go away and
it was becoming like
I couldn't do stuff like it was getting
into my daily it was becoming a problem
it was getting in the way of me doing
things and I tried seeing doctors doing
x-rays acupuncture I tried acupuncture
tried all this stuff I went to a
chiropractor yeah yeah nothing helped
and then when I read that book it's like
it's kind of like telling you that the
first thing is to understand the
connection of
um
how
the stuff like stress or anxiety can
manifest itself in that way and then
like
just by
recognizing what may have caused it like
if there was a moment that you can think
of that was super dramatic or something
happened to you and that you have an
effect
um just even becoming aware of it
already starts relieving the pain
and it really did work
there you have it
um
yeah but I was watching Housewives last
night and this one woman's an alcoholic
yeah she goes to an acupuncture and he's
like oh oh the place of we're talking
about Housewives of the OC by the way
Shen and Shannon bedore he goes oh the
place of addiction is in the ear
right here
so she goes and he just puts one needle
in her ear and she goes you can put
needles anywhere else you go no no
that's where the addiction is in the ear
that's acupuncture bro there's one
needle in the ear and then you're not an
alcoholic anymore wow it's awesome
what are you saying Olivia why is
acupuncture the only reason I work here
when I was sending emails over and over
again to try to get in touch and
get a job
um I wasn't hearing back so I was like
okay I need to find a different way so I
went through
everybody that you guys followed on
Instagram to try and find an indirect
link and it turned out my godmother had
done acupuncture one time on someone who
worked at Teddy fresh oh that's how yay
that's so funny what yeah but I remember
hold on hold on I remember it was chew
who yeah yeah yeah right who's like hey
you should get a hold of them yeah I had
never met him before so wait why did he
recommend you because he was like
dramatic about it my godmother texted
his wife and was like how do you like my
goddaughter says that you follow these
people on Instagram and she was like
yeah he actually works with them so so
funny and then I got in touch with Jill
yeah he was like yo there's this this
young or like this girl who she's really
super talented he was like talking you
the [ __ ] up oh my God that is so nice
and then we and I was like okay I'll try
her as an internship if two recommend
her and I was like God no please no
recommendations by friends yeah then
Olivia came and I put her ass to work
and she was great and I was like okay I
love her oh thank you but Yes
Acupuncture did something
okay it's done something shout out
acupuncture one point by the way please
don't try to social engineer my life
anyone listening to get a job here thank
you it only works once it works yeah
maybe let's live it out once oh you
socialize my life maybe no you you
offered me but I was like hell yeah
but since you mentioned
um Shannon bedor I love the OC
housewives by the way we've been like
I've been catching up and I just decided
to start on season seven because I
didn't know how far back to go
and it's been amazing yeah and we're now
in season 15. oh my God it's kind of our
life is almost caught up literally our
life and time it's like The Hourglass of
your life except it goes down a drain
a sand catcher
well anyway
um listen we've got oh my mom's calling
in a little bit later apparently my mom
saved the butterflies the butterflies
went from no
oh I thought I thought they were already
in danger though no no it's actually the
opposite everything that you're saying
well not that she was responsible but um
yeah no no because this year was like
the biggest butterfly showing well
that's what your mom had so maybe we
should Grill her on that because they
have uh been designated as an endangered
species now no I thought it was good
news yeah sorry I just want to say a few
people are saying that's their favorite
one and I kind of think it's becoming my
favorite one too because the OC ladies
are like the realest yeah they get like
dirty and messy
and watching Beverly Hills after
watching the OC it's like just watching
some fake phony like [ __ ] surface
level nonsense
that's the original is it not no this is
the original that's like the first one
at all yeah yeah so the the first
housewife ever her name's Vicky
and she finally now got booted off
because she got so nuts she was telling
the other girls this is my show I'm the
first housewife and we don't do that
around here like two of the housewives
were making out getting traffic making
out which is crazy and she's like I
don't like to kiss him this is my show
it's a little bit homophobic and then
she says to Andy Cohen during the
tell-all we love Andy Cohen oh Andy
Cohen who made this whole series she
turns it and says Andy don't forget
where you come from yeah and he's like
[ __ ] don't you forget where you came
from and he kicked her off the show
it's awesome I'm telling you this shit's
crazy bro I don't know how you find the
group of such crazy people yeah the peak
of this
franchise though C1 was when uh Vicky
was dating this guy Brooks and he he
faked having cancer yeah it's [ __ ]
nuts he's seriously faked having cancer
and then some of the other ladies
started to doubt him because like things
weren't adding up and and vika was like
going ballistic on them like are you are
you blaming my boyfriend of Faking
cancer like what kind of like toxic sick
person you have to be to accuse someone
who's going to cancer or faking cancer
crazy it's like but he did at first it
seemed like they were like overstepping
so hard by accusing of Faking it but
then you start to believe because like
they have these crate these incredible
like doctor recommendations he's not
showing up to he suddenly stops doing
chemo and says he's doing
taking some random drug that's supposed
to do something and one of the girls was
like that's what I have in my beauty
cream that does nothing for cancer and
it just starts snowballing and then you
start to believe dude he's faking cancer
yeah and then it turns out Vicky was in
on it a little bit I'm telling you this
is high drama like you guys never
imagined yeah
to what
ended up manipulating emotional
manipulation so he was it was very toxic
to her so nobody liked him and so the
whole time on the show he was kind of
like a villain and getting a lot of hate
so he was trying to get sympathy but
he's made it so much worse for himself
well Vicki's super rich and he's a
deadbeat he's like unemployed deadbeat
okay and I think she was always on the
verge of of uh breaking up with him
because her daughter hated him all of
her friends hated him everyone in the
show hate him and so he spun this cancer
story I think too yeah keep keep the
juice flowing and it worked for a minute
right he did get sympathy but in the
beginning
if I have to guess it's maybe like 10 or
11 I don't know yeah dude I'm telling
that was one of the best best [ __ ] ever
dude and then um some people were asking
if I watch if I watch Potomac I do I
love it that sound looks good and then I
watch the ultimate girls trip
it's all she watches I'll be honest so
Ally watches all these as well I don't
really but we have we share an office
and so oftentimes just being hearing it
in the background is Potomac the one
where one of their husbands was like
very obviously gay and was like
constantly getting caught like grabbing
men's asses yeah uh yeah that is the
Australian guy right yeah yeah it's that
one's [ __ ] awesome I kept like
hearing that I'm like what is going on
yeah
you've gotten huge trouble for groping
one of the crew members yeah on the
production team right and he ended up
suing him and it became a plot point of
the show
like just like yeah that guy's nut yeah
wow yeah he would yeah some dude's ass I
haven't watched Atlanta yet or New York
that's Atlanta you got something to look
forward to you though yeah anyway
enough about that
so we got my Mom calling in Hassan owned
Cobra Tate in a debate which was awesome
um pretty soon here uh we said 2 30 so
maybe if we have something let's shorter
than the Hassan thing let's talk about
something I'll take a call from my mom
and then we'll do the period pain
test so
um we bought a little kit you put
electrodes on your stomach
and you can turn up the voltage and it's
supposed to simulate cramping period
pain so that men can feel it a little
bit now we test wrote it on Olivia
yesterday so that she could tell us how
accurate the pain was
um
it seemed that you thought it was pretty
close I think so what I was trying to
explain earlier is that the electricity
that comes off of these things that is
causing your muscles to contract that is
very jarring and that's not included but
like the pain that is underneath the
electricity that is real oh different
sensation but similar pain level there
are two factors with this there's one
factor you know what I mean yep now what
was interesting is that
a few of the guys tried it and you guys
said four was like
pretty bad right me and Ian tried it and
yeah four was pretty rough and it's six
is the max eight I believe right oh
eight
because Olivia was chilling at five
yeah we don't know how because me and
Ian like we didn't last that long once
we had really yeah it seems like fun it
made me laugh
tickled tickled I'm curious I've never
tried this stuff but um I just gave
birth with no epidural so Queen [ __ ] the
the contractions were real so I'm
wondering if the ladies should try it
first to see how they do and then see I
think we should do one one one okay
okay
so that's I'm sure this is going to be a
wild ride
um it's my mom she said my mom's on uh
she's not yet uh she has the link I'm
trying to get her on right now we did
say 2 30 which is seven minutes from now
so if we got any other like videos or
shorter little things we can do
we have
um fresh keemstar cringe
oh we do oh that's right we do that's
like a faucet that just remains on all
the time hey Chicago is that Fosters
buddy you're wasting water
uh here's keemstar jumping into the lake
with his bandana on
is there sound this time no
dude you really swim in your full outfit
and Tennis Shoes
and bandana I love the last minute the
last minute grab to hold it on pay
attention he puts his head his hands oh
no can't fly up ah yeah uh
foreign
cool
um
also here's a stream that was from
yesterday just to keep you guys updated
and all the happenings here
he's with Brantley
by the way you guys did some Intel
Brantley graduated and
we we don't we don't know for sure it's
just we have we have reverse engineered
and find it
uh highly incredible that she's funny of
drinking age and and your best guess
would be that she's at what age maybe 20
maybe 20. 19.
but obviously we don't know for sure but
the timeline doesn't really make sense
so okay okay
I'm gonna invite him and see if she does
it
bye guys
the Hannah we know yeah
she's here what's happening bro
it's less about what's happening just
the the Angles and the expression
especially Just For Men beard well let
me show you this photo this is important
context
she posted this and she said to refer to
the three of them as Daniel's Angels oh
God
I call him Daniel's charges they're
gonna regret this so bad and then what's
interesting is that keemstar said in a
in an interview that he's in
A polyamorous relationship uh before you
do that why don't you just have a seat
right over there and girlfriends they
don't look very old yeah
what was on the agenda tonight
But but so she's so one of the girls who
joins is one of the of Daniel's angels
[Laughter]
oh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hi oh my God
oh my God I just caught this because I
wasn't at work leftovers was live I was
at the doctor's office and I was
standing in line for the pharmacy and so
I had to screen record this on her last
so the audio was good so everyone's
looking at me what are you watching yeah
you seem pretty confident on the
internet but that's pretty awesome that
you are the one that recorded this the
price we pay for uh fresh memes yeah
these are always things I get all of
them but this is this is one of my first
Originals so yeah yeah
you look cute in your little ghetto all
around the world
what get up you couldn't can't even see
what she's wearing yeah
get that money
I was just hanging out with you guys I
was like they make me so happy look at
their smiles look at their faces love
these people oh we love you
oh my god beautiful day out there though
you guys just answering some questions
yeah pretty much done a little q a we
were bored we're waiting for my friend
to come over from Toronto all right well
thanks for having me guys I gotta get
back to work but I'm definitely here
watching you guys
who who does this who does it like this
it's his it's his okay
I have to defend him with that because
he has the most steadiest hands in the
game oh I do not know how he keeps his
video it might be a secret that we have
he's got a selfie stick selfie stick no
it's not a selfie stick we thought that
before but we ended up watching footage
and we can see the reflection it was his
hand yeah it was just magic with it he's
probably got you you've heard of that
one uh
uh Buddhist uh master in India who put
his hand up for to show his reverence to
God and he kept it up for so long that
it got like rigor mortis and stayed
there I think that's what's going on
with campus Because Rigamortis said it
in his hand
yeah pretty amazing he's just a reptile
monk with this is evident that he's not
human why don't you take a seat right
over there
here let me show you a picture it's
really interesting
this this reminds me of keemstar in a
way
here he is Guru wizard guy has his hand
in the air all his adult life oh my God
yeah he never put it he held it up for
so long
that it became locked in that position
Elden Ring character who does that
oh there is yeah there's the guy that's
like always like oh Elden ring yeah I am
yeah but you could if you slip the phone
in there that'd be a good selfie
situation yeah
so shout out shout out
[Music]
thank you
I don't know
I got it dude what are you doing okay
you can't be serious
I can't believe what we're watching
dude you can't be serious okay let me
see let me see let me see what's up in
here
are you sure you can see
oh my God shut up all right your mother
is here if we want to go to something
yeah
after after that just a little there for
you
a little bit of a
little bit of a pick-me-up yeah all
right I'm letting her in right now
let's go
my mother ladies and gentlemen Donna
Klein
joining us the butterfly Queen herself
hello Mom
I thought you saved the butterflies why
are they endangered now
you know the butterflies were always in
trouble and that's why I was so at or am
active in in doing something about it
but you know when when I was on your on
your podcast I was trying to scream from
them from the rooftops that the monarchs
are big trouble
but didn't I read that the last year was
like the biggest year on Rec or recent
record for the monitor there was a bump
in their population over the winter on
the uh the monarchs that were west of
the Rockies but it's bad it's really bad
and you know what there's a an
international Union for the con
conservation of nature they're called
the iuc
iucn and they put uh the monarchs on the
endangered species list but you know
what the fish and game the U.S fishing
game they recognize they're in trouble
and they're endangered but they're not
on the list yet they probably won't be
till
um
2024. what are we gonna do about it
about it
well I mean plant plan milkweed
that that are are
um active in in putting them on the
endangered list it's just you know the
problem is
it's it's the pollution it's it's the
greenhouse it's there's so many issues
um show me the notes how many notes you
got for today
I well I have two pages tell me show me
show me just front and back
yes yeah okay nice oh front four pages
yeah that's four pages wow so you have a
you have a lot to share
I don't want to forget anything and so
let me ask you this what's the benefit
for the butterflies of going on the
endangered species list
because the government will put money
aside to make a difference
you know between log you know we we have
herbicides and pesticides you know that
round out stuff it's it's horrible it's
just like a blanket over the farmlands
to kill insects and it kills it kills
everything and then of course you've got
you've got global warming and
um
you know it it's it's just awful can I
ask you a question mom yeah we're having
a debate earlier on the show
and I had the hot take that
old people are holding on for too long
to like big job like important jobs I'm
talking about and politics I'm talking
about like doctors lawyers all this
stuff they're hogging opportunity
they're not passing the Baton especially
in government uh is that ageism or do
you agree with me
as an old person as an AARP Member
you know I I think you need to go with
the best qualified
said there's a time when you have to
realize that you're not as sharp as you
used to be
and it's I think it's really important
to be supportive of someone who believes
the same views as you and to help them
but I think it's time to move aside and
and there you have it from an old person
herself and Mom uh Laura this is a more
extreme opinion but I do want to get
your take uh should I was thinking can
we euthanize old people at 80.
will turn us into food yeah yeah or
we'll turn you into glue or something
productive yeah
that would be that would be bad but you
know do you know that there are 41 000
species that are facing extinction and
and um are waiting to get on that list
the U.S food and game
um you know who's to say they're less
important than the monarch but
you know it's it's really bad and and in
the past 10 years I think the scientists
are really worried because in the past
10 years the decline has been so rapid
can we see those Nails mom
throw the nails off
okay you want to talk about the nails
what we got going on there
pearl white
how's it now we're gonna talk about
butterflies but we're doing both okay
but I don't know the acrylic are they
glued on so long are they natural I yeah
I just had her cut cut him down
these are my nails
they paint stuff over it to me so it's
half real half glued on
no they're not glued on they're my nails
underneath but oh that's your real nail
yeah it's my nail
over it with some kind of like an
acrylic uh
thing and it makes my nails strong so
they don't break got it got it wow real
nails ladies and gentlemen incredible
[Music]
incredible and how do you open a soda
with nails that long
you use a utensil well you don't even
try yeah what other things do you have
trouble with with nails that long
what what
buttons buttons I thought she was gonna
say butt yeah what about wiping
you know jewelry would like what you
have to hook
um a necklace or something similarious
impossible yeah but Ela does raise a
good question how do you wipe with nails
that long
I cannot but well first of all I have a
bidet okay good there he is
[Applause]
weirdo
I mean it's a valid concern I don't know
what's so weird about that
okay so bro so um the butterflies are in
trouble we need to plant more oh let me
let me let me spitball here what if we
go after the species ahead of the
monarchs and speed their extermination
so that we can get the Monarch higher on
the list is that a solution oh that's
interesting
okay well you're not willing to do
whatever it takes
[Music]
so I don't think these monarchs are
going to last well they better they they
I mean they're like they're
it's just really it's just really bad
you know this is like the um
I'm trying to find where I wrote this
but this is like the six
uh
Extinction
that that is taking place uh in in our
world and but it's the you mean you mean
yeah a mass extinction event
yeah it's the sixth math Extinction
event but this one's man-made
it's all our fault that also could be
propaganda
no it's not oh okay uh I mean
Dan's trying to throw something up is
there any uh yeah there's there's some
Expendable could we like maybe any of
these that Mom can you see this list so
these are all the endangered animals
above
the monarch butterfly and we're just
wondering which ones can we just
eliminate maybe those Black Rhinos if we
just got rid of those I mean those
aren't in the United States so I guess
those wouldn't be prioritized I mean go
down to the endangered these ones are
all fine but there's a lot of endangered
ones that we could get rid of just
straight up you know right blue whale
who needs that thank you oh okay oh
Olivia Olivia black-footed ferret bonobo
who with the [ __ ] but no no no wait
what's going on here are you afraid of
Worlds I don't know I just hate whales I
don't know like love the whales
absolutely do not want them to be
extinct they just terrify me because
they're so big really oh my God the idea
have you seen photos of people swimming
next to blue whales that's like my dream
I want to do that someday
all it has to do is open its mouth and
you're gone forever they don't do that
they won't do it though
it could no they I don't think the blue
whale's ever eaten a person but it could
really easily but I want well what
scares me is sometimes they breach near
boats
and that would [ __ ] that would kill
everybody well they jump out of the
water because they want to get the
Barnacles off their bodies oh is that
right that's interesting yeah that's uh
that's a part of it they're just trying
to get the Barnacles can you open that
list uh down please again
a lot of people find well scary how
interesting mom pick five I animals on
here that we can extinct right now no I
can't I can't and you're just then you
don't care about the butterflies are
really in trouble too go down to the
bottom because these animals are all too
cool I keep thinking about Theodore he
says the word extinct so funny it's like
it does something what's an earwal Wadi
it's synced oh it's a dolphin what we're
gonna we're gonna become extinct because
with the global warming you know it's
it's really effect on on people's lives
on the way here we were listening to the
Daily about the Salt Lake black spider
monkey do we need that
yeah yeah
so cute yeah we need him
um
the Salt Lake of Salt Lake City is uh
drying and apparently if that one goes
completely dry it's going to be like a
nuclear bomb that went off they said
ecological nuclear yeah
I mean you know it's a whole domino what
about God damn these are all pretty dope
animals this is a problem this is kind
of hard to decide yeah
what's a southern oh southern rock
climber penguin okay let's take a look
at this
so cool yeah we gotta keep him
uh maybe Mom I'm learning that the
butter the monarch butterfly maybe the
least cool of all these animals no a
beluga whale how am I gonna am I gonna
uh I'm down with a beluga whale they're
so cute that's a good size okay that's
an awesome size yeah belugas are they're
super smart super sweet and super
awesome all whales are smart okay what
about a plain spices what's a white
rhino you know you don't like bison that
you say you think they're scary right
because they're like fuzzy and cute I
know they're so cool
you gotta decide who dies when you live
keep going I can't do it God all these
are so the brown bear I mean I'm not
gonna get rid of a bound bear for
Monarch butterflies
yeah yeah this is really sad actually
the history of the of uh of the Bears
and their and their hibernation the
other day do you remember that
what
the the story about the the Bears and
their hibernation that they they can't
reproduce unless they have 20 body fat
keep on doing oh I didn't hear about
that
place on the list
wait it's already there
well actually I think yeah but that's
not the food the fishing game this is
worldwide yeah this is just an
organization yeah
so they're not they're not stepping up
no no they they recognize that they're
in trouble they're two steps away from
Extinction not seals yeah I know what
the [ __ ] seals oh the whole coastline is
like full of seals well we've gone far
enough down that it stops saying in
danger so maybe these are just oh these
are least concerned what oh these were
and now we don't even have this is just
a list of animals okay and and all of
them and additional animals you might
enjoy here's a seal for you everybody
just take a look at that yeah you can
find a seal at pretty much any Beach in
California coastline they just chill
okay so we went down too far but
unfortunately I'm unable to kill any of
these endangered species mom so it
really was looking like last year at
this time
I think we took a vote mom the Monarch
is the least
uh the one that we would probably kill
if if it came down to it
you need pollinators Ethan last year at
this time I released about 50 some odd
uh monarchs and this year you know many
have released how much
10. oh what does it mean
it means they're in trouble
oh no that crypto [ __ ]
all right sorry
well maybe this is my milkweed um
hydroponically
you want to see my my milkweed let's see
your Hydroponics
that cushy Kush
let's see those Hydroponics
okay
flowers on him it's a really great way
to not have to worry about aphids and
just really control it so that they
don't get infested with protozone
parasites or takanid flies and the
monarchs that are released well the one
that I released at your house for your
belated birthday
that I mean they were huge they were
healthy and they were huge but
there was only 10 of them
it's been so bloody hot out here right
yeah and and I even had to bring the
cage into the house because it was so
hot they would have died in their
Chrysalis had I not done that
all right well we're rooting for them on
we're rooting for you unfortunately you
know it is a very crowded list of really
cool animals so
just saying well you know what they said
you know no one did anything until uh
there was no one left when they came for
you oh that's that's that's a that's a
that's like
isn't that about like Jews and stuff
like or yeah white people not doing [ __ ]
to help like minorities what do we do
about it what does that mean how are the
butterflies helping me what does that
mean
it's supposed to be like first I didn't
know first they came for the uh Jews and
I didn't say anything and then they came
for the Gypsies and I didn't do anything
and then they came for me and there's no
one left to speak for me right but what
did the butterflies do for me
well after we go extinct the butterflies
live happily ever after yeah it's a
weird right if we all died they'd be
like sick
well you know the pollinators without
them you won't have fruit trees you
won't have you know foods that is true
we need the pollinators yeah they're
pollinators too
so and they're the most recognized uh
butterfly in the entire world how can
you let something so beautiful and
Majestic go extinct it is very magical
when you just see how it goes from a
chunky little
um caterpillar to this beautiful
butterfly it's like it's like watching
magic it is it there they are they're
they're like little angels flying and
fluttering and um you know it it the the
counting is kind of difficult it's
easier to count them when they're in
Mexico to know you know how they're
doing because they cluster in in such a
small area but in on the coastal side
it's really hard to you know figure out
the numbers and man they've really
declined it's terrible mm-hmm
um do you know who else is declined mom
what you know who else has declined
you because your last name is Klein
all right thanks Mom for calling in all
right we're gonna save those damn
goddamn butterflies the last [ __ ]
thing to do
all right yep right there right on we
can't hear you
right here all of the you know everyone
in office because we we need what we
really need is we need the government to
have safe havens and plant milkweed and
they have to do something along the
roadways because roadkill you know you
finally get these beautiful Majestic
butterflies and then they're they're
getting smashed into your wind field
what are we gonna do about it along the
roadway these beautiful plants and that
attract the butterflies and then they
get killed ow ow all right we're working
on it a plant above the highway so it's
like a it's like a safety bridge for all
these pollinators and insects here enjoy
this mom uh
you are the butterfly Queen
can you see that
there's they they I got a beautiful
piece of artwork with uh with the
monarch butterfly oh yeah I sent you
some art that was nice yeah anyway mom
you got you do good uh get out there and
uh save those goddamn butterflies you
know what I'm saying oh Ethan we're
gonna start with you
okay what does that mean
plant some milkweed in that gorgeous
yard of yours okay okay we'll do it yeah
okay let's let's
put our money where our mouth is plant
milk weeds you're asking me to put my
money where my mouth is you put your
money where my mouth is
wow I'll give you some of my plans
I'm just joking around she says put your
money where your mouth is and meanwhile
I'm saying I mean death to the monarchs
because those other animals deserve the
club I'm just saying I mean seals are
monarch I mean you know what I mean it
feels blue whale all right actually
extinct I don't think oh yeah that was a
it's too low or like a black rhino an
African elephant or a monarch you know
what I'm saying yeah I think the blue
whale was on the list yeah blue whales
are endangered yeah I'm saying would you
kill the who would you take Monarch or
blue whale
that's not a fair decision to yeah oh my
God you guys all right really Mom thank
you so much for the call we're gonna
we're gonna we'll plant some milkweed
and we'll update on the show okay you
want to plug your cameo
because the people that request cameos
from me tell me interesting things and
request interesting things and I I take
it to heart and I do a lot of
investigative uh you know I do research
before I talk to them because I want it
special that's cool that's so sweet that
is just incredible
Donna climb on cameo
and uh it's just you're gonna get a
heartfelt potentially a 20 minute video
for my mom I've seen some of them they
go and go and go and we love that
all right well I love you guys I'll see
you Saturday okay all right bye mom
thanks for the call
the monarchs are in trouble
what are we gonna do what are we gonna
do about it is this covet related I'm
growing my hair my hair people
yeah um also so let's do the the period
pain simulator now before we do there's
a few more people watching now I just
want to remind everyone that tomorrow
Saturday we will be live streaming a
reaction to tippy toes
here for Members Only
so it'll be at one we said at one
thank you thank you so please join us
tomorrow it's gonna be a lot of fun I
gotta use the bathroom
good so yeah um
yeah we gotta save those monarchs guys
telling you what
just crazy what's going out there
oh check this out does this give you
Icky vibes
this was like a wild James Charles
found in the background of this dude
dancing check this [ __ ] out
look at this
dude he's looking too closely bro
he's not missing a second of the action
huh I Now understand the root of the
problem
look at those but these other guys
aren't even paying attention
and James is so thirsty bro
what do you think about all that
it's just funny how he keeps getting
caught just like the smallest thing now
if it wasn't James Charles I wouldn't
nobody would look twice but the fact
that it's James Charles makes it so good
like what the [ __ ] nobody else is even
paying attention look at have you ever
even stared anything that intense in
your life bro
yeah he's like they don't know I'm
watching them
desperation what do you guys think about
all that it's pretty interesting
horror movie vibes
yeah
all right so we are getting people wired
up so Zaki baby's gonna go first huh
okay so we're strapping Zach up now
to the electroids yeah
pretty strong we just uh actually I
don't want to scare Zach he's a little
worried about this but oh yeah spooked
straight yeah exactly he was saying he
didn't want to do it yeah Zach was like
I'm not doing it but I was like wow okay
you should be wired up now now just to
be very clear to everyone
there are no Shenanigans we are not
pressuring anyone to do something
uncomfortable we're not going to
surprise jump up the meter this is all
very careful very consensual
stop means stop should we have a safe
word
safe word is
oh just stop safe where it is stop
yeah we're not doing like stop
this fight yeah so there's there's no
Shenanigans okay we're only going up as
far as
the recipient is comfortable I'm nervous
can we get a shot of them setting up
there um who's got the handheld
oh yeah yeah let's take a look
so Zach you actually look scared right
now you look scared straight pretty I'm
pretty nervous right now dude you
watched me do it yesterday it doesn't I
I
got the same stuff that people
wear on your back when I was trying
different things right
[Music]
okay so Zach is getting straight he is
absolutely terrified at the moment Well
Jack you don't have to go up any higher
than uh you don't want to okay buddy
okay
so let's take a look at the electroids
can you show it to the camera
or is it already on you yeah do you mind
lifting your shirt you don't have to
we've got he's got four total two on
each side
[Music]
yeah they look too close together yeah
oh you got to spread them out a little
bit there
good
off my eyelids are so itchy all right
it's the weirdest place to I don't know
this what happened last time it's like
the weirdest place to be itchy and the
skin they're so sensitive yeah
ah
all right so are you ready all right so
it goes from one to eight so I'm gonna
start low get it get a shot of um
get a shot of the meter so we can see
the the intensity and then if you switch
to Zach's camera in or would we have a
good shot of that okay all right
all right I am activating we are at
level one okay level one one shouldn't
be that too bad at all do you feel
anything Zach no no nothing okay all
right so I'm gonna start
yeah you just turn it down it'll take me
a split second to turn it off it's all
but hey Zach what if he accidentally
turns it the wrong way not that bad Zach
don't worry wait what if he turns it the
wrong way thinking he gets confused well
that could happen Ethan yeah
all right go ahead and move up to two
Dan all right we're increasing
[Music]
going up
you feel anything yet still not really
all right we're at number two Zach feels
nothing sit on it for a moment
nothing you feel nothing
okay okay we're gonna okay there it is
okay oh [ __ ] what are we at what are we
at right now just three I feel like one
and two don't work it's like nothing and
then oh that's [ __ ] weird super light
okay Zach go ahead and describe the uh
sensation it's uh tingly very tingly
okay are you experiencing any pain do
you feel that it's a little discomfort
yeah okay yeah I feel that okay so four
now keep in mind Olivia got up to five
and was still like
doing okay and said you know that was
kind of now you you said five was the I
said five I'm not going to rehearsal six
I'm not going to school
you know like extracurricular I can
cancel at five I can't do anything at
six so wait wait at four are is that
like before I'm going to school okay so
turn them up to four Dan all right we're
going to four here we go so this is
where okay man
[Applause]
this is Olivia we're going to work with
this oh that was weird this was me this
was me yesterday yep
yep
describe it Zach it's like tingly but
like electric oh it's weird yeah the
electric part
are you willing to go up or are you done
what are we at you're at four
I thought of my five no no you need a
five dude but if I say stop stop Olivia
was chilling on five like just passively
for like a few minutes ago okay okay
okay okay
[Laughter]
how you feeling
what do you feel oh
different
[Laughter]
are you going to school like this are
you staying home
I'm going to school
are you doing okay I mean we have more
Headroom yeah I know you I bet we do
just a reminder at this point Olivia
says oh yeah I feel it now okay now she
said it about
okay so Zach um are you feeling like
maybe it's time to move it up to a six
or you take me to six but if I oh [ __ ]
you don't have to worry about that I
will definitely all right Zach is going
up to six all right here we go
oh my God that's weird oh
okay turn off turn off turn off all
right wow
okay wow all right you made it to stick
that's big those are big numbers
all right I wonder how will it affect me
since I have a big old stomach you want
to go next I think one of the ladies
should go next I think because it's
electricity that maybe isn't a factor I
don't know my Fat's gonna get cooked
I'm gonna get deep fried
crispy
does anyone want to uh uh Sam's not
doing it so either Olivia or uh Lena or
Alina Olivia or Ila anyone I can do it
okay Lena is she getting up to you okay
Lena will do it
oh my God my stomach is like still
vibrating
okay Lena's gonna get strapped in I'm
gonna go to the bathroom real fast I'll
be right back
my stomach is still like like vibrating
and Contracting it's weird
[Music]
yeah I'm gonna do it
[Music]
all right should we wait for Ethan or no
I mean
we could I don't know
[Music]
all right so I'm gonna go to one okay
starting out
[Music]
all right do you feel anything no so
that's it one and two
he didn't feel anything it wasn't until
we got three that even started to feel
it so why don't we just Skip To That All
right so we're gonna go to three
oh okay
[Laughter]
um
very different response than Zach it's
weird it's really weird we're just
having fun
oh my gosh what are you feeling right
now
it's just fun
[Laughter]
so so you want to go to four yeah do it
all right here we go
[Laughter]
all right we're going to five it's
Fickling her she's up to five now wait I
want to ask
oh my God
I just want to know how does it compare
to a normal period correct um I don't
experience it that bad for me I just get
a little bloating that's all oh so this
is okay okay all right but you're ready
to go
this isn't painful
we're at five already
yeah okay wow
yeah all right let's go six Lena's
moving up to six
oh my gosh
I'm trying to feel it oh yeah yeah yeah
okay it feels like something's bouncing
on my stomach it's weird yeah yeah you
start to like you feel your muscles
contract like when you hit five for me
what are you at six right now
all right here we go seven are you
running are you running
wow that's interesting so no pain just
yeah
do you want to go for eight you're right
there you might you might be the only
one
okay wow
um no pain
[Applause]
it's like a lot of pressure and tickling
that's what I found it's interesting so
it doesn't it's not reminiscent of a of
a period cramp for you personally no you
don't really get not for me
there you have it Lena is the new
champion at seven
oh yeah and she did it with just a laugh
and a smile the whole time
no problem for Lena Xena Warrior
Xena yeah
[Applause]
Disney princess with a high uh paint
tolerance
there it is
built different
[Music]
okay now A B obviously has been through
grueling training he's boxed he's got
that conditioning
how's your pain threshold there AB you
think it's pretty good pretty high yeah
pretty high
so we expect great things of you yeah
all right go ahead Crank It Up just just
if you could maybe describe
the sensation and damn as you raise it
tell us you're raising it and then maybe
if you could expect I'm gonna raise it
slowly but I'm gonna go all the way up
to three to start because it does people
are saying they're not really even
feeling it until three so all right okay
okay here we go
[Music]
the first jolt is very shocking all
right we're at three what did you hit
yesterday I went to four I went to four
and I stopped it okay it doesn't seem
like too much trouble for you there okay
this is three three okay I'm a little
afraid now okay all right
[Laughter]
ah it's weird it makes your muscles
contract okay
that was an involuntary sound it makes
me laugh okay well that is what uh that
is what the cramp is so yeah
all right so five
you ready to go up yeah
yeah
I'm good all right we're going to five
[Laughter]
okay
that's [ __ ] I thought this was a
normal chair or the [ __ ] is the back
okay huh oh oh I yeah I keep going it's
weird yeah
are you still on there yeah we got when
I felt one of them okay so what do we
got five five what Lena go to she went
to seven bro okay don't even try to
compete all right you good yeah all
right we're going up the sticks
[Laughter]
now is it pain maybe or is that your
feeling is it pain
ah it's
no no no keep going one more I'm fine I
don't feel anything wait maybe is it
pain you're feeling or just no it's just
weird it's just okay okay why is it
bouncing around it's going from left to
right oh Dan are you [ __ ] oh no no no
yeah he's not he's not he's not gonna
okay I remember doing that yeah we are
not [ __ ] with me it's just it's
steady at six right now okay
ah all right do you want to try and
match your girl yeah oh wait this wasn't
the match okay yeah I thought it was
about the one on first so wait he's
going up to seven now all right all
right here we go
[Music]
so what's the if it's not painful what
is it you're feeling
oh it's like no no no no it's like it
sounds like abs are being forced to
contract I don't know how Lena was
running though because that's the last
thing I want to do I just want to like
curl up I know it's weird that she was
running
all right well you have one level left a
b yeah do it oh [ __ ] just [ __ ] do it
all right three two one
you're gonna shock me dude
is it maxed out
I wonder if he's just lost the ability
to talk remember when he fell off the
chair
baby can you talk yes okay
okay all right let's wind it down Dan
let's let's wind it yeah wait that
thing's not even on man you know what
you know what's more painful is the the
uh the rotating of it how how it's
bouncing because like you think you're
at Max and he goes and they're like not
you
Ethan you gotta try this thing oh [ __ ]
I'm next I mean you don't have to be
next but I'm definitely gonna do it yeah
should we do Elena yeah let's just do
Ela because you have pretty painful
period cramps right no but you don't
sometimes like after birth my periods
were worse than my normal ones I see but
on the regular not so bad oh well here
we come we're gonna put it on
well done AB very impressive all the way
to Abe wow we
okay we're setting Gila up here
you can compare it to childbirth you're
the only one in here that can compare it
to child contractions
but like there's a specific spot right
it's like it's like kind of like one two
and then one two well it doesn't matter
where
you want to turn it no no I think that's
okay I think do it lower and then they
should be further like that Dan
yeah that seems good okay and the same
thing on the opposite side okay so Ela
is applying the electroids electrodes
I have a lot of faith in Ila she's got
it she's gonna handle it I think so I
think so let me take a look
okay it's just too high because it's
kind of over your ribs here maybe just a
hair lower on the top ones so it's not
like okay that seems good yeah but these
are close it doesn't matter
um try to lower that one maybe I think
it's okay
okay here we go so Ela is strapped in
this is gonna be a big one guys the only
person here
who has given birth so Ela as it goes up
just describe your experience I'm
curious how does it compare to period
cramps and childbirth contractions okay
all right all right so I'm gonna do the
same that I did for ab I'll just go get
a shot of her stomach I'm curious if it
starts pulsating
because that's where the pain seems to
uh start
alrighty Ela
all right you know it's so funny like I
I did this like as a relaxing thing on
my muscles so I don't know can you turn
a little this way so I just want to see
yeah yeah all right
that's three okay yeah you feel it and
so not bad no pain just a little muscly
just a little like ELO's not even
affected at three
so I'm gonna go to four here we go yeah
okay he was feeling it you're doing a
little rock and roll devil horns it's um
it's like yeah it's like
and and does it remind you at all of
period cramps or childbirth
um
trying to think not really not really it
just feels like you're being
electrocuted yeah yeah yeah yeah right
yeah that was a question I was wondering
all right so let's go to Five yeah yeah
all right going to five
oh
we have a now we've got an owl from Mila
yeah that's not it doesn't feel good it
doesn't feel good no
ow oh I see your stomach kind of yeah oh
yeah yeah so it doesn't feel good
um it is the first time like gets you
but then you get used to it yeah
so you're feeling okay now yeah you want
to go up or you want to call it yeah
let's go out okay what are we going to
six six now this was Zach's Max right
here it seems like the six and seven get
to the hardest
uh
ow
what are we gonna do about it oh what
are we gonna do about it
now when you have contractions you just
want to breathe just breathe breathe
you've trained your whole life for this
right but she was getting tickled I'm
not too cold so it's different seems she
had the most fun of anyone being
electrocuted
all right let's go up all right seven oh
you let's go into seven
wow you didn't even Flinch on that one
and I would say it seems like seven to
eight maybe not that bad based on on um
I just AB didn't really react but I mean
I will tell you that when I was having
contractions I couldn't breathe I
couldn't talk sorry not bridge I
couldn't talk so it's much worse than
that I'd imagine it's much worse and you
can still talk and breathe I can still
talk
but does the pain remind you that's what
I'm or is it just totally different
totally different okay interesting yeah
all right let's do it all right wow
three two one
There It Is We're maxed up I didn't
notice no response no difference no
difference oh you made it all the way to
eight you Legend now I can chill like
that you can chill yeah
wow wow
bring her down bring her down wow
this is weird
it's weird yeah it's my turn I'm gonna
be you're not gonna like it
now I'm concerned I'm gonna look like a
giant baby yeah
and by the way here I want you guys to
actually see my stomach here because
okay
well I want ELO to see I need to give
the support I am concerned for you can
you put the tape okay yeah let's get
those electrodes going guys all right
can you really I think your legs down
are you comfortable I'm comfortable okay
I don't know how fat is gonna interact
with this
so this goes on one side
have the wires for my hours I feel like
right coming in from like this those
both are on the same side oh yeah this
to our one side
there okay and then just mirror that I
mean I I just remembered I was doing I
was trying to do this to ease my back
pain it's like a relaxing thing
I wonder how high they went but I didn't
go high like three like maybe five okay
are you getting a good shot of this here
let me turn towards you maybe wait don't
turn it on you Dan I'm so scared I'm
gonna be a giant [ __ ] baby right now
Zach what did you get to oh six you got
the six uh Lena got the seven Ela and a
b both got all the way up to eight but
with very different reactions
all right so do you want me to just go
to three because again three people
slowly go up just slowly yeah slowly go
up and stop it free here we go
oh yeah it doesn't do it it doesn't do
anything and then I'm going up slowly
one or two there oh let me get my mic
one at two there's no feeling
all right
what is that number three no it hurts my
fat is like cooking bro
it hurts so bad though in you it feels
like it's pulling my hair
there's no way that it didn't this hurt
like really bad wait why does this hurt
so bad wait wait wait wait wait put it
down put it down and down no lower wait
okay let me move these over a little bit
because this one didn't hurt that bad
and these ones were like killing me you
have to put them like on your your
uterus is down here your uterus is all
the way down here did mine a little high
too I think you want to go lower
that something didn't feel right about
that
serious I think that's how it feels
Ethan well but this side was fine okay
but they pulsate so maybe that's why
that would be an epic prank if none of
us turned it on
I was like there's no way that you guys
okay that felt so [ __ ] up
dude that would be a good prank you guys
aren't doing that right
okay go ahead go back up to three go
back up three and three two one but do
it slow I was hoping
there's no [ __ ] way to hurt you guys
this much it does yeah I think it's like
it's just like it's weird and witching
bro no way it's very uncomfortable at
first but you can't get used to it right
but it is painful
I don't doubt it
all right try going up to four all right
oh my God there's no [ __ ] way there's
no way that you guys didn't hurt you
that much we will have no children if
you had to be friends no I'm telling you
dude that was not right you guys aren't
fat I had something to do with being fat
bro what the [ __ ] wouldn't it be the
opposite like fat gives you some cushion
you would think
oh my God you guys no no no I swear to
God that hurts so bad
hell no hell [ __ ] not ow
that's so wow
ow ow
and what about Harry's stomach you have
a hairy stomach Zach right yeah
because I think maybe the hair felt like
it was hurting I'm just saying all you
guys I have hair it's just like blonde
you know I have hair you want to do it
to Dan well Dan's definitely going to
have to do it but you don't want to try
one more Ethan are you done hell no bro
I was like the three's okay and I went
up to the four and it bro it just didn't
feel right you gotta let it sit I know
it's shocking at first and then you get
yeah that's so painful that's what I was
the electricity is like really shocking
so you have to let it sit but the thing
is I didn't feel my muscles Contracting
just my fat boiling
I think we all have different ways of
describing it it's just a very
uncomfortable thing at first but you
felt the the muscles Contracting because
I didn't no I I don't know if I could
say that I don't know
foreign
what did you get to four yeah I bailed
it for try five why not
[Music]
yeah show me what show me the placement
okay yeah that's good yeah yeah oh
Alfredo cam
what about Shredder why isn't that there
oh my God
you can show Shredder just don't just
show them like a top side you want me to
control it for you
he's like what what's going on
what are we doing
come here all right so let's go ahead
with Dan all right here that's gonna be
my uh get on over there maybe with my
guide here
so yes so each one is each side and so
here we can just turn it on to start
because it doesn't really do anything
until you turn it up a little bit and
here I'll just do it start
okay so Dan is strapped in oh that's
three Dan has more hair like me so I'm
wondering if that affects
it hurts right
it's yeah but do you get used to it if
you get let it sit it's it's weird
all right let's oh I just I don't know
it felt like really painful and y'all
were like it doesn't even well I now
understand what Olivia was saying
there's there's two distinct things
going on here there's the there's your
muscles tensing the [ __ ] up but then
there's just that buzz of being
electrocuted if you've ever accidentally
touched a outlet or whatever or the
prong on a yes plug and that's just
that's just constantly happening so was
it would you say it was that or the
muscle they had all electric no muscle
maybe maybe you're right maybe the
stomach thing but that said before I
agree I think dude there's like a fat
three inches of fat before you can get
one yeah so maybe it wasn't even
affecting your muscles all right yeah
you could crank it up to four all right
we're going to four all right okay let's
see what Dan's got
[Laughter]
a moment
that's not great that's not a great
feeling dude if that's legit what you
guys are going through once a month
I mean yeah yeah that's [ __ ]
just let's go to five oh okay Dan is
going for it
hi Lord
oh it is
yeah Dan is standing up that you want to
stand up yeah and is standing up he's
coping
with Lena laughing
I don't know how is that possible I'm
just saying the skinnier people are
having an easier time no don't find it
I'm just saying
and not take it away from us I'm just
saying it's an excuse
oh my God Dan's going to six
[Music]
and just remember Dan
bruh seven and eight there doesn't seem
to be a difference right
in my opinion
getting used
every time you kick it up it's you know
yeah the first second is like oh boy
let's go
Dan is going up to seven which is
basically all the way up I think
it was less of a jump already
like from six to seven let's just go
let's go all the way oh [ __ ] that's
like that thing
was there a difference between seven and
eight Dan barely okay
okay
I mean
yeah what was the point of doing this
again
well yeah it sucks yep
it really sucks yeah the point is that
we're trying to empathize uh you're
doing it for the women with the ladies
yes
we're sending love out to the ladies
yeah yeah yes we feel it yes
there you go Dan going all the way to
the top I'm glad we did that
it was a great little experiment
oh yeah I feel like I just did like 100
sit-ups like I am stomach muscles are
wrecked right now ah that's see I I
didn't feel it in my muscles at all you
guys
been enough time I was at four bro I
felt it Contracting like totally
um
um good job Dan anyone else thank you
wanna try it
oh yeah we should get Ian in there and
cam
[Music]
so
it's a beautiful new background though
some people are suggesting to do it on
my back so that I don't have the fat
excuse
oh that's interesting I would be willing
to try that I mean if you did it like
yeah
I did say yesterday like a lot of the
pain that happens during periods is in
the lower back there it is there it is
that and you feel that in contractions
too you feel yeah in the back too all
right so I'll do the back and then I can
see if the fat conspiracy is real or not
or if you're just a [ __ ] it might just
be that I'm a giant was
Cameron grants everybody's getting
geared up right now
it
cam the one and only
getting geared up are you hairy Cameron
he's pretty hairy okay so I'm just
curious about how these different
components play into the feeling he's a
sexy beast the thing is my back doesn't
have hair or fat so that could be a good
experiment
you have a hairless back yep pretty
interesting
all right Cam's sitting down right now
I'm gonna pass the mic over to him hi
everybody
Cameron with this beautiful soothing
voice oh thank you let's see if he can
keep his
Tim Timber while being electrocuted
we'll see
you must hear that all the time Cameron
that you have a beautiful voice and to
be honest I don't really think so myself
but I appreciate it yeah but you didn't
answer the question you hear that all
the time right yeah yeah are we on
okay
all right Cameron is moving up whoa okay
yeah is that three okay
oh is that a three is that a four now
four
Cam's at four you know it's it I feel
like my tummy's shaking right now right
uh but I can I can live with it okay
okay
move them on up to five
right is that five now
all right we're at five and
oh
what are you feeling are you feeling the
electricity or you're more your stomach
muscles I'm feeling both of that all of
the above yeah yeah oh my God yeah okay
this is fun
thank you
um let's go up let's do it wow going up
two what is this six
cams at six yeah that's a six
[Laughter]
[Music]
I yeah I'm really confused how Lena was
like giggling and running around right
now but you know I could I could live
with this too but I'm definitely not
going after school curriculators with
this exactly yeah
dude you could live with that uh I mean
like
by keeping it minimal I'm not screaming
like a girl bro panicking at four like
witch girls these
what is this
I was screaming like an Ethan yeah like
a like a what is this device used for
actually
is it a torture device or what it's back
pain okay let's go up one more let's see
if I can do it
we're at seven oh okay seven I didn't
really notice much of a spike there
actually never mind I spoke too soon
dude it feels like somebody's pushing on
my tummy oh okay yeah
Christ uh okay yeah that's this sucks
dude this sucks
let's go to eight though I just gotta
get I gotta rip it up rip off the
Band-Aid yeah
okay yeah I don't really notice the
difference between the two
it goes back and forth because I was
feeling it rotary once it got past six
dude it feels like somebody's inside my
stomach like just doing a mosh pit in my
tummy right now you know right
everything's moving around
oh okay we can I think we can call it a
guy yeah so did you go up to eight yeah
wow did I I think right
thank you very much
impressive showing by camera that was
impressive
[Applause]
another fatty in the office too I can't
I can't tell if it's my hair on there if
it's communal hairs um
I had that same thought all right let's
get my back good job cam
let's go baby shirtless
you were pretty chill about it cam
yeah he handled it pretty well where
should I where should baby put these
Olivia the low back like on the two the
sides get it right where you would put a
[ __ ] stamp
yeah
okay is that low enough
you want me to put it in your crack yeah
I want you to I want you to try to
that's good like like low hip
low hip so if can you go lower for the
other two bro that's your ass you do it
you do it I don't want baby to have to
touch me there
get down there
get in there this is what marriage means
it means putting [ __ ] in my ass crack
[Laughter]
yeah get in there
so are those too close or you think
those are fine put one on your desk put
one on my ass crack put one on your
Gooch you can
I think this one will be it'll be better
I have a good feeling our lower back
we're strapped up
no no no no no no don't give it to her
no I can't do it okay
all right guys I cannot administer pain
okay here we go all right what do you
want me to start it just go gradually up
to three okay red one yep we are at two
yeah I don't feel anything like okay
there I got okay okay I got that three
going yeah it's I'll tell you right now
it's not as painful oh interesting okay
okay I mean it's it is painful yeah
right right it feels like tight that's
right it's like a magnet is pulling my
muscles towards it that's right all
right go up to four maybe
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you know what's kind of nuts the bottom
is still working you're involuntary
working right now really yeah
yeah okay go up to five
ah
feels like bee stings bro ah
oh that hurts so bad you guys serious
you don't think that hurt it feels like
bee stings we're all like a thousand
bees it's the electricity that hurts
yeah
it does hurt but I don't know it's this
one on the top right here that hurts the
most it's like a little dagger dude the
ones on the bottom are not that bad or
no they're bad what am I at five five
that's where you're at right Zach
oh I went to six no you didn't you liar
oh [ __ ] I don't want to go to Six it
hurts all right try it and then stop
it's gonna hurt so bad all right go up
to six here we go
oh [ __ ] me in the tits [ __ ] [ __ ] in
my mouth [ __ ] [ __ ] baby
oh God it hurts so bad when you turn it
up yeah it's like getting it feels like
being stabbed man yeah that part is the
worst it's just when you turn it up it's
like little [ __ ] daggers bro yeah
uh [ __ ] baby [ __ ] ow
oh
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] does that mean you're
doing another one you feel your back
spasmine no no every so often you do a
little oh yeah
I don't know bro I didn't really want to
go up anymore put one on your Gucci one
of my goods yeah
six at least I went as high as Zach yeah
seriously all right go up to seven
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
deep breath slow yeah and then slow
release
my body's so tense just relax
[Music]
I'm telling you when it was on my
stomach bro it felt [ __ ] up like
something went right there it was so
painful
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] my [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
oh
yeah it's still on all right I mean you
made it yeah
turn it off you get used to do it ow ow
[ __ ] it hurt going down
oh my God a lot of hurt going down
you did it you did it take that [ __ ] off
oh it's all numb my whole back
yes
hell no but I'll be totally honest it's
still electrocuting that hurts yeah yeah
you're just being electrocuted
thank you guys
oh [ __ ] baby you see I'm not a wuss
screaming like an Ethan like a little
[ __ ] baby Ethan
oh [ __ ] bro
in fact you want to go for eight
go on go for eight yeah
oh Ian yeah I want to see Ian yeah bro
oh my God oh my God do I have to have
it's like what you know what find
people's belly button lint and yeah
sweater little
juices I mean you don't have to possibly
even
um dingleberries from my from my back I
know that thing was pretty low possibly
even some schmeg I was diving for gold
back there my [ __ ] almost prolapsed I
almost had to call Howie went out
to make a tick tock of my butthole what
do we do about it
so it's a middle a little misleading
because I would say three four and five
hurt the most yeah I think it's just
that you get used to it because we were
doing it gradually I think you get used
to you kind of get it because I just
felt the most like it was like oh [ __ ] I
agree that last stretch from like seven
seven eight it wasn't too big yeah
all right well is Ian getting strapped
up or is he out on the dingleberries
it sounds like he's out I I mean I could
do a job if it's cleaned off oh you were
you do want yeah I don't know this is an
easy way to do it because it's got that
like gel we must have some some uh
sanitizing wipes would it take off the
stickiness though
right
yeah it's like a gel Sticky Thing yeah
can bacteria survive being electrocuted
oh my God my whole body was so tense
yeah when I went to eight and then
realized and relaxed my body and I got
more used to it and I could have sat I
could have sat like that for
for a long time yeah once you get there
and you relax your body
oh I'm so glad I redeemed myself you
guys would have never well done well
done let me live I'm Googling around
right now actually to see if like uh
putting the contacts on an area with a
lot of fat like makes it more painful
fat Theory foreign
I'll hook it up one second all right Ian
is getting strapped up here
Ian
with the pregnancy pain
oh [ __ ] bro
oh people in the chat were saying and
they'll stay sticky even if you uh um
how does that work what kind of magic
material is that I don't know somebody
somebody in the chat said uh they'll
stay sticky if you watch them
oh [ __ ] oh throwback here we go ready
Here Comes
[Music]
man that was fire hit me with that one
more time round two it's like a Jimi
Hendrix lick
[Music]
oh
[Music]
I almost feel like you're saying
employee it throws me off
you hear it
[Music]
Queen
[Applause]
thank you everybody thank you thank you
I love that um
everyone had to just really push it
didn't they yeah we all had we all had
well once um
all the way up first
you actually stopped at seven which is
basically eight let's be honest yeah
right she could have easily yeah I
blamed Lena for this uh Landslide all
right Ian let's see what you got all
right just just do three
okay here we go in uh the full-time
employee that's right salaried and
everything so now that this is on your
skinny and is it a bad time to tell you
about my crabs
I knew about that
okay I don't feel anything yet I don't
care is that three
you don't feel anything really that
seems wrong yeah that seems wrong wait
crank it a little bit more
no Ian has no Sensations something's
wrong yeah it's gonna go did cleaning it
mess with it
this wiped it off it should be fine oh
oh wait oh there we go oh hold on hold I
hope there it is oh I'm just feeling it
on half though oh oh wait one of them
fell off wait oh
no wonder you don't feel it
not on you
yeah yeah
going back back to three
[Music]
okay
yes you feel it yeah yes yeah okay okay
good it's working so what do you think
the reason's not too bad uh I tried it
yesterday oh you did we got to four yeah
I think I'm gonna be four thousand
you're gonna be fine yeah go ahead go to
four
[Music]
okay yep
[Laughter]
yes yes sure myself
dribbled out prolapse that anus Daddy
I'm I'm trying to
uh keep in mind like it gets a little
better once you get used to it I think
it does yeah but it's that jump seven
eight ain't nothing bro what's that four
this is the worst five is the worst
let's get to five let's go to Five is
bad
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah I'm like feeling it in my legs I
feel your legs I felt it like in my
whole body I really did yes I've lost
all motor function down there
he's still switching look at this
[ __ ]
switching
through the pain
what is this at six you're at five [ __ ]
just once you conquer that six you're
good once you do good yeah okay all
right jump it jump it jump it
okay
is it really painful for you I mean it's
definitely uncomfortable yeah I would
describe it as very painful I don't know
so everyone's trying to sugarcoat it and
my experience was not uncomfortable you
would do this for fun
like you turn this on have a good time
so did you try to relieve muscle pain
back pain yeah
oh that's really nice
[Laughter]
part of my apparently like physical
therapy that's what the doctor told me
yeah oh it's okay interesting I mean it
may not have been that hivable it
probably was like five though I think oh
really well you're at seven right now
just go for it Ian is quivering his lips
hmm yeah here we go
you're up all the way buddy you made it
what second got you and can you do
switching is that eight yeah
keep switching
[Applause]
thanks guys all right
wait you're not gonna stay like that
during the whole show is that that seems
weird that's right jump to five wait it
hurts no wait it hurts to go down it
does if you do it fast I yeah he turned
it all off for me and it [ __ ] me up
AV swish it off real fast oh I'm just
stuck up here now oh turn it down slowly
brawl it Roll It Roll It
no this is great this doesn't come down
yeah oh you're actually nice the release
is nice yes what's what's the big deal
with period cramps it's nice no that I
will say that was not a good time and um
my you know empathy is going up because
my condolences all right and next up Ian
we have a jar of pizza
but you got to do it when the things
that ate yeah oh my God slamming the
fish
okay thank you thank you good job there
Ian all right
[Applause]
and Zach are you looking for a
Redemption are you happy where you're at
you could try it on your back if you
want or nips or nips or balls exactly
next if you do two nips earlobes
these
all right butt cheeks bring it on I'll
do it on my stomach again okay here we
go Zach is going back in you know I just
want to give you that redemption or
because we all made it to eight I
appreciate that and I would hate to
leave you
uh without a full redemption or there
do not use it by your heart that is good
advice we will not be using it on our
hearts thank you
you know speaking of electrotherapy
there's this new technology for people
with multiple
sclerosis you know when that when it
gets really Advanced they shake
uncontrollably
so they developed this new technology
where they put electrodes into your
brain
and send like a shock a little bit of a
shock like that and it cures it like
[ __ ] like washes Ms brain shock
therapy and you got to see I mean it's
just so incredible
um
[Music]
I saw one on Tick Tock the other day but
I guess it's
fairly
oh man I'm geared up
whenever you're ready
um
all right Zach let's do that
all right Jackie take me to four first
Zach's going straight
okay don't do it at once Jack's up to
four this and so you have one more to
match your previous attempt all right
oh so you wouldn't you did the worst of
it yeah once you're at six you're
basically there seven and eight ain't
nothing take me to Five okay Zach's
going up to five for a Redemption Arc
here we go
Zach go ahead
how you feeling
it's weird man it's the jolt
oh my God I can't I can't do it dude
you're so close
I take me to six I'm Gonna Stand once
you're at once you're at six you're I
gotta stand up dude stand up get it done
all right video you got this Zach I
found the one I was looking for
others
all right Stacks chilling at six he's
standing
this is seven or six six you got this
buddy
okay that's not bad okay there you go
there you go seven
there it is Zach's going for it
Redemption Arc all the way
all right hey all right deep break into
eight take me eight take me eight go
home baby oh baby
[Applause]
there it is go say thank you to
Chantelle tonight
[Laughter]
oh okay
all right you can bring him down now
uh well done Zach Redemption Arc is
completed awesome
good job everybody yeah yeah wow
impressive stuff
by the way here's the video I was
talking about yeah so this guy has um
oh it's he has Parkinson's
and it makes him shake uncontrollably
and they install electric a little bit
of wires into his brain and send
electric signals into his brain check
this [ __ ] out it's like miraculous okay
so we're here for the initial
programming session
we got both sides of the brain put in
bilateral stimulators and was here for
the initial programming session
this is what it looks like without the
medicine in the stimulator and now we're
just going to turn it on
I can get my fat fingers to hit the
button there we go
see how it feels
dude watch his face he's like tripping
out how you feel
about that yeah
can you believe that should I tapping
both your fingers for him
so crazy yeah it's it's awesome dude
excellent
all right
feels pretty good shot what the hell
can you imagine man okay so we're here
that's amazing actually there's another
one love sent me I haven't seen
let's see it's nice to see this stuff
makes you feel good yeah with your
stimulators off
I just wanted to Mark what your Tremor
is like
okay you happy for that to go ahead
foreign
okay on the real test do you think you
could pick that up for me
such a hard disease yeah it's so bad
[Music]
right okay should we switch off
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so cool
okay you're right
[Music]
[Music]
dude
oh [ __ ]
stupid ass [ __ ] [ __ ]
no it's making me cry
yeah that [ __ ] God bless you man
so that's a nice thing so electricity is
it's electrocuted your body isn't just
fun and games
we're definitely a claimed by those
[ __ ] [ __ ] how dare you monetize
something that sweet stupid asses God
I'm tired of getting claims it's been
like all week
and our first video for Monday still
isn't [ __ ] fixed
still no
oh still not fixed
just processing
I I talked to my guy from YouTube again
today and he said the swap is still not
done geez I guess I did something to
piss off the Instagram God
um
anyway so there you have it
we did it got boys you did it Joe we did
it Joe and uh shout out to the ladies
thank you wow we appreciate y'all so
much incredible
there's one other thing we got to talk
about which is um
our very own Hassan [ __ ]
got the opportunity to debate Cobra Tate
the human trafficker Mr [ __ ] is one
keeping helping monk of a man and he
absolutely [ __ ] hunk of a man bodied
him do you understand how much did you
watch the clip I did Andrew so Andrew
I loved every minute of it
Hassan was trying to make one very
simple point which is empirically women
are actually better drivers than men one
of Cobra the human traffickers
points he's always trying to make is
like I don't think women should drive
they're not good drivers and you know
all this chauvinistic like insanity
and he's like listen empirically that's
just not true you're wrong and Andrew is
so incapable of Defending his position
he starts to could be like you're boring
bro nobody wants you here
um which is incredible because Cobra the
human trafficker is perfectly defined
debating other people he does it all the
time by the way he's doing a stream with
like a bunch of 17 year olds I mean this
these are his people so here is it was
kind of long
the whole thing was no it so the whole
thing was uh about like 20 minutes 22
minutes we tried to cut it down because
at certain points Cobra is just so thick
and not getting it that they are just
kind of going in circles so we reduced
it I think it would wind up like 11
minutes or something all right well
let's give it a why it definitely gives
you the idea of what's your girl yeah
this has made me change my opinion a bit
I was thinking like anyone that has him
on is is not good but Hassan really
clowned him I think it is it made him
look like a little worm it's good
Hassan he told me that he Andrew is down
to have a full combo with him which I
hope happens that would be awesome you
know
I feel like I could own Andrew in a
conversation pretty hard too
I don't know if he'd want to talk to me
though
although he knows who I am so that's the
start
I think the problem is that someone like
him just immediately will make fun of
your weight that's fine it's like he
could do that he won't like when I feel
like when Hassani was like speechless
you can be like you're fat you're fat
yeah [ __ ] you're just you're just mad
because no one's a [ __ ] you yeah he does
try it at one point right then it sounds
like I have no problem with women well
he goes he's like oh I see what you're
trying to do you're just hoping one of
these women drive to your house
it's like
yeah
um anyway let's watch shall we
yeah he's gonna degrade and the
countries where men still stick to their
honor and their their age-old expected
ways of of acting are there going to be
a safer societies overall so time will
prove me right but I have nothing
against it that was you guys did a zoom
on that yeah this [ __ ] and one
of the one of these kids is straight A
Booger Eater on stream y'all
so time will prove me right but this is
Andrew Tate's friends bro
what the [ __ ] why why just do it like
that like what he's so used to eating
his own bugs that hits like second
nature to him you just ate your own bug
bro
[ __ ]
Shameless my dude
Andrew
I showed them there's a screenshot where
the guy on the top left just like
casually oh we we uh you got it yeah
then that's emphasized in this as well
it's so Andrew Tate though to be hanging
out with a bunch of dudes from high
school
you eat their boogers it's awesome
your work uh as you're doing the rounds
on Twitch here and uh a lot of the
things that you said that you've been
called out on specifically in regards to
like women driving my nervous as a
matter of fact are just generally untrue
there's no empirical evidence to back up
those claims which is why you resort to
anecdotes quite frequently and say
things like oh well it's just common
sense right
but it's not technically common sense
it's just your personal opinion
completely it's my personal opinion
based on my personal biases of my life
experience I I I find that he always is
trying to get away with it but he can
justify anything he says by that because
the audience is a bunch of children he
goes listen you can agree with me or you
can disagree this is just my opinion and
I think Hassan does a great job of being
like it's fine that that's your opinion
but you understand wrong yes right yeah
right which is I think yeah he he
[ __ ] this is great when I say the
yeah exactly and when I say these things
x amount people agree with me and x
amount of people disagree with me that's
fine and that's the same of nearly any
statement in the world okay I can say
the world is round and there'll be a
percentage of people who disagree with
me
and personal biases
and when we analyze situations we do not
have enough scope to grasp the entirety
of the situation we didn't we cannot
comprehend it with our human brains bro
listen why when it comes to women
driving
I noticed that Andrew keeps trying to
speak over him and Hassan just alphes
the [ __ ] out of him like he's always
talking over and making him beta
beta the [ __ ] out dude because the truth
is different the truth is the exact
opposite Woman face no no listen
first things first there's lies there's
damn lies in their statistics I'm sure
you've heard that from Mark Twain that's
the first thing the second thing is that
you're you're derived yeah you can
massage numbers but you can drive you're
deriving your truth from an internet
study that's fine you can derive your
truth from in a study on a bunch of
different things the truth of life that
is the truth that you experience as an
individual that is the only truth that
we all live within you live within your
truths I live within my truth because
the truths I've experienced as an
individual it's you certain things
happen to you over and over and over and
over and over again but the truth on the
internet says it's not true that doesn't
mean that your experiences are any less
real 15. so if you come here and say the
internet says X especially your
experiences can be real you could be a
statistical anomaly as a matter of fact
you can be one of those people but more
more often than not more often than that
I want to talk to you because I keep
letting you talk and you're finishing
your point and I'm trying to talk so
okay go ahead I'm going to the fact that
you're going on the internet finding
some study and saying that this is the
truth especially after the age of covid
and all the [ __ ] truth we were told
with that girl you
looking to eat another booger there dude
a few times he gets close
that did I'm talking about my personal
experiences and some people agree with
me and some people do not that is
perfectly fine don't give a [ __ ] if
people agree with me or otherwise people
are listening to me and they're either I
know but you're still wrong and that's
the problem and I disagree with you you
want to be right or do you want to keep
speaking into a hug box where people
agree with you if you just completely
devalue empirical evidence Actuarial
Sciences the entirety the insurance
industry that relies on making these
sorts of calculations to ensure that
these quotes are as profitable as
possible which ends up uh charging men
higher rates than women as a statistical
likelihood happy that yeah
slam dunk the insurance industry right
is entire it's a billion dollar industry
predicated on calculating risk right so
that they make money and they charge
more for men and General on insurance
because drivers yeah men are more
expensive to ensure yeah because they
get more accidents
men are more dangerous drivers than
women across the board and get into more
car accidents across the board if you're
going to look at all of that and say it
doesn't matter because that does not
correspond to my own personal uh my own
personal experiences then you're silly
you're being silly cool and my personal
experiences all the car crashes I've
been involved in all the times my car
was hit and all the negative experience
we're at fault that is now you can sit
here and say you can't be that you just
sound so stupid no like you sound like
of caveman bro I see I see women hit my
car a woman bad driver
it's like dude come on there's a whole
world outside your outside of your lived
experience
also I doubt that's even true you know
he's the [ __ ] crashing yeah also
who's there every single time what's the
common factor why are you getting an
accident
yeah yeah
and think of it from their perspective
every time they've been hit it's been a
[ __ ] dude named Andrew Tate you're
there every time trafficker
insurance claims say that I never said
the insurance claims don't say that I'm
saying that I am not comfortable with
women driving because of my personal
experience those are my personal
experiences he's not comfortable with
women driving period that were I was
literally I was talking about this
earlier him saying that he is
uncomfortable with women driving it's
just like that much
more annoying of him because it's like
so patronizing to be like I don't know
if I personally feel comfortable with
you on the roads right it's like sir I
mean it's straight like fundamental
Islam I mean like yeah I was told I was
the best Parker in the office yesterday
well there you [ __ ] oh man
Eat Your Heart Out Andrew Tate thank you
by the way horrible news he's about to
go on the nelk boys podcast and you know
that's just going to be a huge L for
human disaster
[ __ ] elk boys oh god dude
you know Kyle that they're gonna be like
dude that's so true huh I'm gonna say I
don't think I don't think women should
drive dude that's so true in it I'm
gonna go rip it
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you can drag up all the empirical
evidence in the world you want to try
and drag up anyone with a brain knows
how that aids the world agendas anyway I
don't want to go too political taken
down so I'm I'm not saying that I can't
fight a female race car driver I'm not
saying that that's not what I'm saying
either I'm not talking about I'm not
talking about like uh statistical
anomalies I'm I'm straight up talking
about the overwhelming amount of
evidence that suggests that women are
more careful drivers than men okay and
therefore better drivers than men
now you keep resorting back to uh your
personal anecdotes you under so let me
walk this let me walk you through this
right do you agree do you agree that
human beings have biases yes do me a
favor do me a favor okay okay
but I respected your time do you want to
answer my question do you believe that
human beings have biases
oh absolutely we're all biased okay
completely do you think that those
biases might Cloud your judgment
it's not about clouding judge not just
your personal cloud not just your own
personal judgment do you think our
biases might Cloud our personal judgment
I think every single person on earth is
biased and lives within a bias
absolutely that's absolutely true okay
so if you if you agree with me on both
of those again he laid his own grave and
he's basically just digging his own but
he's too dumb he doesn't even know where
this is going you understand that you're
anecdotes your own personal accumulation
of information is going to be clouded by
your own personal biases so you're not
going to be able to assess the
information adequately in the same way
that empirical evidence would this is
precisely why we look at data rather
than make arguments around our wait let
me finish come on I understand what
you're saying that's precisely why we do
that
oh yeah and then the 17 year old start
backing up Andrew you keep making the
same points come on seven times
um it's not getting through I think it's
an important you know I think he's
trying to force him to acknowledge
uh that his point makes no sense which
is important yeah and don't you have
another booger to eat chill bro
I asked Dan if the way that the mic is
in the top right shot if that would
actually work and the answer if he's
trying to mic his dick yeah
he's probably using a headset Mike right
there's no way that's picking him up no
there was one I don't think in this
specific clip but other ones where he's
talking into it like that
cute you're longing the point you're
saying that the empirical evidence is
saying X so it doesn't matter what my
personal experiences that's fine my
point is let me change it let's say that
the empirical evidence says that Pitbull
is more likely to bite you than a
Dalmatian but in your life experience
every time you went near a Dalmatian it
bit you and a Pitbull never did are you
gonna go up to a Dalmatian still
completely and go oh it's fine
completely unbiased because the
empirical evidence says X when you're
covered in Scott bro you're so dumb he's
literally describing like a bias
ours no you're gonna say Dalmatians bite
me for some reason and I'm not
comfortable around but Dalmatians that's
called human nature and so I'm telling
you my personal experiences and I don't
care I understand your point empirical
evidence says x women in this country
can do X I completely get that for a
second country because you're only
talking about America because you're
American you don't see outside of the
world that's fine I'm Turkish actually I
grew up in turkey that's not the point
hold on hold on why it seemed like that
was the point actually that you're
trying to make I'm making it I'm
uncomfortable with a woman driving and
if you actually ask most women if it
gets late at night or it starts getting
dark or it starts raining heavily or the
parking gets difficult they usually ask
the man to drive themselves I know many
women who do that they're not offended
can you try oh can you park this car for
me
please it's a too rainy and dark I need
you to park this car for me please
that ever happened by my assumption I
know lots of women go oh I don't want to
park you park it the dalmatian example
that you gave is great you are creating
now a hypothetical scenario in which you
want your opponent to concede what if in
a million times that I have bred pit
bulls or been around pit bulls not a
single one of them has ever been
aggressive we will never be able to
arrive at a meaningful solution
intellectual juggernauts are sitting
with Tate there
[Laughter]
the smell could kill or a resolution
he's like oh oh damn he stinks still huh
it's not even like I
think that was like a rough
uh meaningful solution
operating on personal anecdotes and
hypotheticals so let's change the
subject okay Andrew do you believe well
they're just trying to
be famous on a stream with two famous
people well they're trying to create
viral moments I don't know who these two
guys are but it's their stream they
invited Andrew on oh interesting they're
just copying Adam with the nose picking
100 they're just trying to copy Adam
what he is
boogers
that's a twitch
and they're just trying to copy an ad in
crap
oh it's all the time okay but eating
your own boogers that seemed eating your
own Burger it's not that cool I think
it's not that time I think so
I agree with love
Ian thinks they're just copying it in as
well they have literally no basis to
actually jump into anything being said
whatsoever so they have to do some
trying to be silly maybe yeah yeah well
these guys based on what I was seeing
they have Andrew on and they're keep
bringing new people into the stream too
yeah talk to them I guess yeah
and somehow they decided this was the
most boring one and kicked this on out
I didn't uh you didn't really prove
anything but it's cool uh do you believe
the Earth is flat or do you believe the
Earth is is spherical
round
two years
oh he took his headphones off he gets
very stressed sometimes and you know
yeah yeah it's cool it's important
or baby and he just bailed bailed
without saying anything
[Laughter]
it's a little stress sometimes you know
uh human trafficking is a stressful job
and sometimes you need a breather
sometimes you can't take the heat
sometimes you can't take the heat so you
gotta get out of the kitchen a little
bit
um Andrew do you believe the Earth is
flat around spherical Globe do you
believe it's round right but when you
walk outside it feels like it's flat
brother brother and I I it looks flat it
feels flat but you believe it's round
why do you believe the Earth is round
because I have personal experience that
would prove to me that the Earth is
round oh you have personal experience
what happened did you go up to the
[ __ ] moon is that how you figured it
out
space and I looked down on her
that's crazy look even his buddies you
don't have to Hey listen you don't have
to conceit on that point but I think you
and I both understand the importance of
scientific uh the importance of
empirical evidence in that one right or
or you know
and I thought wow this guy wow okay he's
gonna ruin the stream this is when he
starts yep with the uh Shenanigans you
can you can't deal with it you're just
boring yeah you're ruining the stream
dude with these uh the girls are tuning
out right yeah oh chick now is that what
you thought just just just chill out
like
is it a little bit more difficult when
I'm not like uh the traditional like sjw
looking person is that why it it feels
like the stream is a little bit more
ruined no it's not difficult as a
professional I'll tell you the
conversation we just had yeah you dude
you've been kicked in the face and stuff
like I'm sure you can handle little old
me exactly so I'll tell you that's a
professional conversation we just had I
said I am biased and I don't believe
women can drive that's my personal
experience I don't care if anyone agrees
who came along and said you can't don't
interrupt me you came along and said no
because of the evidence I came and said
I don't care about the evidence of my
personal experience you said I also have
personal experiences and we're all
biased I agreed then you said even if I
had personal experiences that said X I
would ignore them because the internet
told me to believe why I believe what
I'm doing that's not what I said
regardless of my own personal biases
that I might have women drivers being
safe is internet propaganda yeah the
internet told me what the [ __ ] bro
where'd you find that on like uh [ __ ]
uh Reddit uh
nih.gov or some [ __ ]
evidence is still more important than my
personal biases
and you've lost and it's boring you're
boring is that what happened I didn't
just say I'm boring and I lost and then
you win is that what it is do a poll in
the chat and if you won then we'll
continue to talk it but I'm sure you've
lost and it's boring do you want me to
leave the conversation that desperately
Andrew it seems like you're running away
a little bit never any Circle okay yeah
we can move on from that we can move on
from the the what's funny is these kids
like they don't even understand that
they're making the best content of the
day
they kick Hassan out and it's like you
just made your show so much worse this
could have all been iconic if you let it
go
or the importance of Science and and
Andrew's personal biases Andrew can you
tell me a little bit about uh the
hustlers University whatever that is not
in a promotional capacity I know that
like you're doing the rounds on Twitch
and I know that that's probably giving
you a big boost but I want to understand
you know because you are a businessman I
want to understand how you generate
Revenue uh is it okay to get this
information for free or do I have to pay
50 and then maybe get an affiliate link
and get other people to also join so I
can make a 10 cut off of them also
joining Hustlers University you can find
everything on the website and you can
join if you want more information that's
fine so you don't want to you don't want
to share this information for free right
now you don't want to educate me on that
don't want to sit here and spend the
next hour you trying to accuse me of
some [ __ ] I'm not I'm not I'm here
to learn Andrew you are a brilliant mind
the the numerous concussions but
brilliant nonetheless
so I want to hear more about your
business strategy if possible it's
actually quite interesting that people
who are too scared to get in the ring
try and make fun of people who have
bravery to try and make fun of it no I
do think it's very by the way I love
this now he starts getting defensive
about oh I was a fighter and I'm brave
it's like you spend your whole day
trashing on people and now you're gonna
get defense and by the way good for you
for getting in the [ __ ] ring what do
I gotta suck your dick about it it's
like I don't owe you any respect you're
not it's something you wanted to do just
because I didn't want to do it doesn't
make make me less Brave or less heroic
than you that's something you wanted to
do so good for you for getting a hobby
that results in you getting brain damage
like Hassan pointed out it's just not my
cup of tea you know I mean some things
that I do might be brave for me and
other things might be brave for you
for example reading a book
or
a book great for him in a book yeah
uh for for example
um letting a woman drive and sitting
passenger oh that's true I mean that's
ultimate challenge
you know cooking dinner
in a book drinking tap water
I'm just saying you know bravery is
subjective unlike by the way your
opinion about women drivers
thank you thank you Dave I do think I do
think it's very oh all right so let's
let's not let's not let's not detract
The Bravery of men who do things you're
afraid to do that's the first thing no
no you you are absolutely you are a
Warrior brother you still might have CTE
but you are incredibly Brave I I
appreciate it
I mean look at defensive [ __ ] whatever
dude it's fine you're just getting a
little smoke brother you can't deal with
it because I know you want to sit here
and talk about you and try and break it
down and you've prepared a bunch of
notes Etc I have no notes whatsoever I'm
a dumbass I don't know anything I'm
talking about I'm simply here to learn
from you can we stop with the sarcastic
[ __ ] no I'm literally but that's the
truth you're being so so sarcastic
though like look can Andrew not handle
it yo yo yo yo my man you really gotta
you gotta protect we stopped with the
logic here come on I don't want to hear
facts I don't want to hear roll chill do
what the [ __ ] empirical evidence [ __ ]
he says the world is round because he's
seen the curvature just believe that
we want to have a debate but we don't
want anybody to go back and forth yeah
no because that's boring but also don't
try and be funny that's boring chill
with the sarcastic [ __ ] bro you're
making Andrew upset
why are you being so sarcastic I'm not
I'm literally come on come on come on
come on come on come on I'm asking
questions
sarcastically listen have fun please
it's pretty clear
that I was the better Hassan so yeah
that's agreed I agree with that one if
you could just
get out the call maybe it would fix the
Stream I think so would you guys if you
guys would like me to leave the call I
can do that I don't want to be I don't
want to be rude I gotta get back to work
I I do not want to be rude boys uh you
know this is your stream uh Andrew uh
I'd love to talk to you in more detail
if you'd like to I I hope that one day
you can uh educate me on your your
Revenue strategies uh I mean it does
look a little bad though if you're like
if you feel as though I should leave the
call because you feel like I'm
overpowering you a little bit
yeah oh and then well some of the best
parts is after he leaves then they all
start talking [ __ ] about him
worrying bro and he's just so boring he
was ruining the stream he goes listen I
don't care having conversation just
boring it was just bringing the mood
down I'm just here to have fun call to
sauna nerd you're like gonna have what a
nurse empirical evidence [ __ ] you're a
[ __ ] nerd you don't drink bubble
water
it's not even just the empirical
evidence like
when you really boil it down Cobra is
basically just saying he doesn't believe
in objective reality yes yeah like I I
just don't believe in it and of course
he does I don't know I think he might be
such a narcissistic the narcissist that
he really like in his world I'm the only
one that matters I like my opinion is
all
that exists he's just it's just a
rhetorical [ __ ] just he could say
whatever he wants but he knows the world
is round I think it's like Ethan said he
just found answers to kind of like give
when he's confronted like yes it's just
my opinion which usually works yeah like
look you have your opinion I have my
opinion like with pork boy it's like
okay so it's your opinion right I think
that was kind of like the vibe with them
yeah but it was it was awesome to watch
this because like they finally talked to
someone who can really like answer
in such a good way
yeah I mean yeah he did a great job so
shout out uh debate Andy Hassan debate
lord it's your girl it's your girl
here's another Hassan highlight
um he's on the phone with our Aiden and
xqc or favey so no this is later
yesterday he actually went round two
with Tate oh he did yeah after he got
off stream I guess he was on eight inch
stream and Hassan called in while Tate
was there okay yeah at least Aiden knows
what's entertaining and what's not like
those booger eating idiots true
true are you [ __ ] he saw you doing
crypto gambling streams it was like oh
there's a bunch of suckers in here yeah
he's just picking his nose but does he
eat it does he eat it that's next level
he saw you doing crypto gambling streams
that was like oh there's a bunch of
suckers in here that are gonna go
[ __ ] lose all their money bro I'm
here too man
[Laughter]
he saw you doing crypto gambling streams
it was like oh there's a bunch of
suckers in here that are gonna go
[ __ ] lose all their money
chaos yeah
I actually am kind of down to talk to
COBRA now seeing what a [ __ ] [ __ ] he
is
love that ain't it was really really fun
to watch that it's so exposed
well there it is you know it's about 420
Blaze It hour so
I guess it's time to go but again just a
reminder to everybody tomorrow at one
o'clock
party time here for members only live
stream we're going to be watching
we're gonna be drinking eating and
having a generally good time yes what
the Island Vibes man oh this is this is
like the culmination of like how many
years of build up why don't we first
talk about tiptoes in a minute
definitely like in the old office right
yeah yeah should we get Sam can you can
prepare something where we put shoes on
our knees so we look like little
and the role of a lifetime
no let's not do that all of a lifetime
yeah so I hope you guys all join us it's
going to be a lot of fun the VOD will
hopefully not get taken down and you can
watch it afterwards yep
I think it'll be okay
oh what's up
in the island man
in the Coconut stay
no Andrew no cry
when her son asked you what empirical
evidence Noah Andrew No Cry
no Andrew No Cry where's your girl
don't forget to bring food and water to
the girls in your basement
no Andrew No Cry No No Woman No Drive
[Laughter]
that's really good Amy
uh thank you watch family oh watch party
family our Saudi benefactor just hooked
up
King
[Applause]
should I say
Andrew you go in the ring and get
knocked out wait people are asking about
Ace what was the update about Ace family
oh right we didn't get to that oh it's
in the title oh it is awesome Broome has
been exposed by the Ireland boys the
Ireland boys
the island boys
Island Boys
Evelyn we're Ireland boys
[Music]
Ireland boys
wait so uh Nick received a damn from
social gloves asking if he would be
interested in fighting about
compensation social glove said the
budget was really tight and they don't
have any money in the budget to pay him
well at least they're being honest this
time
last time they just were like yeah we'll
give you a million bucks yeah the
screenshot from social gloves from the
DMS pretty much only interesting thing
here but they're like if you want to
take money what else will you take
he's like what's the lowest perhaps to
get you in there yeah or maybe some
clout some sort of cloud Exchange
talked with the team and the budget is
really tight the card is already set but
if money isn't your motivation it shut
the [ __ ] up what's your motivation
social gloves how many uh how many
retweets do you want
yeah a million retweets and I'll do it
if your money isn't your motivation then
we might be able to work something out
might
not saying you would fight for free but
the budget is low what's the lowest
you'll get in the ring for I'm thinking
150 bucks
the same
thing wait did I missed something
just uh distracting me because there was
like there's always stuff on this side
yeah I want to see what you were saying
oh now it's it's down there the fourth
one
fourth one the Beluga yeah oh it's a
beluga I'm gonna tell my kids this was
Elon Musk
that has an interesting body I'll be
honest
um
also a hairless King though
shout out Katie cat meow five gifted
Subs hey kitty cat
a message from Social Club said
what's the lowest you would get in the
ring for
after Nick asked them to make an offer
social gloves responded that their but
their budget was maxed out
Nick stopped responding to them after
that social glove still promote it
posted a promotional poster with Nick's
face on it yeah or a potential match-up
oh [ __ ] bro 30.
that's awesome
well there goes the Redemption Arc
we're pulling for you Austin
let's see the video and see is there
anything interesting in this uh not not
right that's basically it yeah
okay since I was like shoot iron them
boys just trying to make it
the Luck of the Irish boys
shout out to our Irish members by the
way shout out shout out to them boys
and me and Ricky I talked to Ricky about
it I talked to DJ Fab about it and our
friends and I was like man dude what
should I say is this actually gonna
happen like what do you think I should
do what do you think I should do and
then social gloves the official
Instagram account of social gloves dm'd
me saying this hey Nick are you
interested in fighting on our July 30th
card at crypto by the way crypto Arenas
where the Lakers play it's a big [ __ ]
Stadium
so who are this guys these are the
Ireland boys but I'm confused they don't
have they sound American right their
last name is Ireland oh that's yeah
that's fraud I call that uh Rod man
Ireland boys the guy in the right house
like deaf noodles with Jeff noodles
right there
uh but I don't know they're they're
YouTubers and he's trying to get them
involved in the fight I don't know what
this is
Ireland boys
they don't get a lot of views I mean I
do okay you know 100 000 here
100 000 there
some soy face new house
pretty typical pretty typical 2020
YouTuber
lots of arrows
two new houses new house new house
[ __ ] where
that's true anyway Arena and I said
possibly what's the offer and do you
have an opponent and then they said this
not sure what the offer is yet have to
talk with the team anyway I already read
all the details but pretty funny
is it still canceled the fight or was
that all just a publicity Stone uh
postponed as of now yeah so but then his
opponent come out to do tests yeah I was
a little confused about that a lot of
people were a lot of people were
commenting on it but so it actually got
postponed because that seems like a big
deal because you have all the production
you have the arena oh yeah everyone on
standby I mean they were the headline of
the event
wow dude that's awesome
shout out easy Marty for five gifted
subbies excuse me Marty we're getting a
bunch of uh members right now there's
also thank you all right let's go let's
[ __ ] go
Brianna said got my teddy fresh order
today first order and I'm obsessed so
hard to find clothes that actually fit
my body thank you hell yeah
thank you Brianna
[Applause]
got a little Jew or being a member for
16 months love the show can't wait for
tomorrow that's that's it I wonder if
they're like a rapper or something a
little Jews and you
[Music]
anything else I should talk about since
we're here before I sign off
hey oh I want to do the do hey we're out
of time we're out of time yeah we gotta
go
hey uh
yeah
[ __ ] baby [ __ ]
[ __ ] baby [ __ ]
[ __ ]
in my butt [ __ ]
piss in my butt [ __ ]
[Music]
you're in my ear
s
[ __ ] my ass [ __ ]
it tastes like beef jerky
it tastes like beef jerky Journey
yes only in Buffalo
only in Buffalo with the hot fresh real
syrup yo you're in trouble one dollop on
a plate put your fork in it
hey throw your hands in the air if
you've ever ate beef jerky with a fork
come on y'all let's see those hands in
the air
put them up
let's get those [ __ ] hands up if
you've ate syrup
tastes like beef jerky
tastes like beef jerky get those hands
up in the [ __ ] Air Drive Angry
extend your hands like keemstar holding
his phone
oh let's get those Cubes To Hold let's
get those keemstar hold yep here we go
[Music]
I gotta do the podcast like that at this
angle
hi everyone uh Instagram story so you
guys can see how accurate it is I'm
gonna try to do the cube start huh
[Music]
okay here we go
I have to hold it
oh
put your [ __ ] hands in the air
everyone
put the [ __ ] hands
[Music]
I think it looks pretty good
it's not as good
hey put your hands in the air if you
have under girls underage girls in your
basement or
no not me I said put your [ __ ] hands
in the air if you had other underage
girls in the basement bar throw them up
throw them up oh
[Music]
uh 10 year old fan right oh no no no no
no no no God
[Music]
oh no I mean it's putting me in the
vortex oh baby all right guys see you
tomorrow
gonna be a hell of a day
okay
do you have your passport all right take
us out
[Music]
thank you